[Applause]
[Music]
let me tell you something jc i was live
before you told me to go live
i've been live since i was born you
ain't got to tell me when to go live
my mother told me when to go live august
2nd 1970 2 45 pm
smacked him on his ass sent them live my
mom didn't do that
she was too tired man because something
large had just come out of her vagina
so the doctor he was the one that did
the [ __ ] smacking and i still hold it
against him to this day
he'll get his one day welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernard
hey uh welcome kids
excellent to see you again so much to do
as per usual
another episode of falcon in the winter
soldier to recap and review
the uh amazing suicide squad trailer
to dissect and [ __ ] jizz over
um we get to speak with uh the folks
who make those amazing bat in the sun
productions man those batman movies you
watch on youtube where you're like why
can't they do this
with the real movies and [ __ ] um aaron
shawn key
i got that right didn't i aaron yeah i
think you killed it i did i killed
shanky
um we got news to cover we got so much
to do but first we got some
show-and-tell
like i got some cool [ __ ] to show off
man i want you what you got
i got some this is the universe toys
no not the ones mind you from our
[ __ ] show but still
pretty cool [ __ ] but before we do any of
that of course
we gotta give love to the people who
make our show possible tonight
and let me tell you something these cats
i i there must be a lot of ball hair in
the world kids
because i can't believe the good folks
that manscaped
um are still uh buying ads on our show
man
like it must be working somebody must be
like getting out there with the ball
preserver
and the [ __ ] the reviver and then
cracking their
[ __ ] on yes and doing this to their nuts
and their nutty areas or wherever else
they want to use it
manscaped is it must be blown up in
order for them to be spending
as much money as they spend on us and we
thank them for it either that or maybe
mark
we're selling this manscape product out
there maybe the more we talk about it
the more ball hair grows
and it's this weird sort of parasitic
relationship
between us and pubic hair which makes
manscaped folks
very very happy hey man you got you
yeah you you got bush you definitely got
bush man if you haven't tried the best
products
from our sponsor today manscaped um
after using these life-changing products
you're gonna want to join a ball sack
beauty contest kids they got those
mr south dakota please present your
wares
nozzy lifts up a little walks out
[ __ ] completely
you know [ __ ] naked except for apron
little apron around his waist
and then when you're asked to present
the dick is separate the dick is
like tucked up in a little dancer belt
yeah we don't need to see the dick
no and also like that's that would be
dirty
because we're we're only looking at the
balls here this is a ball beauty contest
who the [ __ ] wants
a dick walking in so the dick gets stuck
up under a dancer belt
the balls hang and that's what gets
judged but when you're using manscaped
you're not getting judged they take one
look one whiff and they're like winner
these are winner balls man it's uh if
you
if you uh listen to us we're gonna get
you a 20
off discount man all you have to do is
use the code
fatman20 on at manscape.com
probably should be updated for 21 but
we're still rocking the
fat man 20 codes no it's because they
save 20 and free shipping
for the fat man 20. thank god one of us
is as smart and figured that out you
know that reminded me of the moment in
fargo where i was like
oh it says the tag says dlr so i was
guessing he was writing it down and then
he got killed
like oh i don't know if i agree with
your police work there norm i
think dlr means dealer plates he's like
oh yeah
i'm the other guy marge you're marge son
of a gunderson i'm the [ __ ] other
leader
20. he's right for 20 off at
manscaped.com kids
we can't say enough good things about
the good folks
at manscaped man listen to this this is
the sound
of shorn balls
doesn't that feel good it's gonna look
good
it's got a little light on and [ __ ] look
at that you can do it in the dark
hold on look i'm i'm an episode of the
x-files check me out
hey scully tell me about your balls
there's a mystery we got to solve and
this uh
the mystery is why the [ __ ] do you have
ball hair get with manscape
they're gonna take it off when you trim
the hedges the tree stands taller kids
didn't you ever hear that
from your grandma talking about your
grandpa's dick and balls
like when when he trims the hedges this
tree stands taller
of course something everyone's
grandmother said to him yeah and
meanwhile she was using a strop [ __ ]
razor like
literally giant leather belt crazy
[ __ ] nut scythe
not anymore man that's why i was sitting
there scared he was like oh my god she
might cut me but she was like
when you trim the [ __ ] head and the
tree stands
taller you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah i
thought grandma wanted it she wanted to
keep clean shoring balls
she did not live in a world of crop
preserver man she didn't live in a world
of crop reviver she didn't live in a
world of any attention to balls
whatsoever other than the attention she
paid to my grandfather's balls
herself god rest both of their souls man
we live in a better world
because of manscape man manscape's got
it all kids
get 20 off plus free shipping uh with
the code
fat man 20 which mark explained to us
thank god i needed it explained to me
like i needed
my wife to explain [ __ ] lynch's
mulholland drive the first time i
watched it thankful
for us code is fatman20 it's at
manscaped.com
m-a-n-s-c-a-p
dot com do yourself a favor and always
use the right tools
for your bush trimming experience man
get 20 off free shipping
with the code fatman20 at manscape.com
that's 20
off i said did you hear me with free
shipping at manscape.com
make sure you use the code fat man 20
minutes 2021
you still got bush change that [ __ ]
manscaped how clean do you want your
balls test to clean my friends
test to clean i'll tell you now that i'm
done selling
now i put on my [ __ ] oh
that's the [ __ ] i was gonna say i have
the son
this is my show hat uh william necessary
in chat
said uh if you are exposed if you are a
spokesperson for manscape
does that make you a pubic speaker
that's [ __ ] good who said that uh
william necessary in youtube chat
very nice real last name yeah
as far as i can tell that would be a
braggy last name you know like people
used to like
i'm smith and presumably it came from
somewhere down the road i was
my people were someone was a blacksmith
or whatever [ __ ]
what was somebody was like i'm picking a
name for for
a legacy and it's necessary
you can't kill a necessary person and
[ __ ] can you do without me
i'm necessary it's right there in the
[ __ ] name bert you don't bury the
lead
god damn it that was clever yeah um down
the street's the disposable family and
they're not doing too well no they chose
poorly they feel disposable
let me tell you something uh there's
another it's not a sponsor
but i'm gonna say send you someplace i'm
gonna sell you something
just because i love it uh go to jay and
silenbob.com right now i'll [ __ ] wait
they sell these birthday cards that are
[ __ ] amazing man
like this guy derek eads draws them and
he
like we literally have [ __ ] greeting
cards
look at this one it's based on the
blueprint
all right they're all blank inside cause
you can write whatever the [ __ ] you want
this one is dante i assure you i didn't
forget your birthday
oh how adorable is that where do you get
those wonderful toys mall rats moment
this one is the
[ __ ] a card that is also a dress me
up
so cut out paper kev and then you put
outfits on them
this one i want to get a box of this
[ __ ] it's my kid
from ruby reboot who wants cake she's
holding the knife
like [ __ ] that's crazy i'm gonna get
like
1000 of these and just like constantly
give them to her for holidays and [ __ ]
be like
it's your card or she could whip him out
like my card
this one is uh brody birthday shmurfday
this one is of course our you know our
boy jay
you the bomb yo um and then this one is
a really great secret stash one that
looks like
you know a back of the comic book ad
that's very cool
my god these are [ __ ] gorgeous please
buy them
at jsonbob.com man derek eads is the
artist
and you know i i'm just so impressed by
them like
we've made a lot of weird trinkets and
[ __ ] like you know i'm a man who likes
to make souvenirs and whatnot
i like to merchandise but i never saw
greeting cards man like in our future
uh that just makes me so happy um all
right
where to begin let's let's begin with a
little show-and-tell
yes please i look at this i you know i
get send things i
i go shopping for [ __ ] um this was
something that was sent
to me we'll start with this piece it's
gorgeous
i i think it's from the folks that
i don't know who made this but oh
sideshow
look at this [ __ ] giant stan lee
oh wow so and look he's got like
the head the different shears and [ __ ]
like that
it's [ __ ] huge man stan lee barber
from the sakara planet
one sixth scale collectible figure man
from uh
the good folks at uh sideshow what is
hot toys
presents movie masterpiece series
[ __ ]
gorgeous goddamn words anyway
thank you to sideshow they sent that to
me
um this is um masters of the universe
stuff they've been putting out the
classic line again
so like you go into walmart and get it
this is coming
any minute now look at the brand new
land shark now this is based on our
cartoon this is just
the old classic line that they're
redoing gorgeous [ __ ] land shark
gorgeous [ __ ] battle cat
doesn't that look like a happy childhood
doesn't this just remind you
look at this though if you got a battle
cap you got a panthor
son uh they use the same mold
just like they used to totally um here
are some figures tri-clops
excellent
ram man short and stout
spring loaded clamp champ oh
dead sexy um
merman
roboto all these characters figure into
our our miniseries as well
but this is the granddaddy of them all
right here
with every child holy [ __ ]
i'm gonna get it all in the frame look
at how huge this [ __ ] is man
it comes with a special sorceress figure
there's on the back you can see
[ __ ] you know everybody they don't
come in the box but they're all the
people that go there but it comes with
the
temple of darkness sorceress man
you open this box kids and it's the 80s
all over again
they're very hard to find jc anyone in
chat
talking about how hard these items are
to find
uh people are freaking out about how
their childhood has been brought back
but i don't think anybody's talking
about how hard they are to find
i can uh i can talk on that though
because i frequent the toy section of
target and i've seen a lot of the
he-man but i've not seen any of the
other characters or the castle of gray
skull
castle graves both go very fast and they
cherry-pick
of course the figures you know when you
send an assortment of figures there's
like
10 he-mans and then you know one this
one this one this
so they're going [ __ ] fast they're
going everywhere and stuff but that's
mattel re-releasing like you know
more articulation with the old sculpts
or something but then when
when masters of the universe revelation
drops
on netflix um very within the next
few months kids there'll be an
announcement soon they won't let me say
anything
i've known for a while but they won't
let me say anything um
then there's a whole different line of
toys
that are focused around those designs
so you know we're going to get to walk
into toy stores into targets
and not find the toys
based on our cartoon for years i've
always
gone chasing other figures that have
sold out
and now someone presumably will be
chasing
our figures from massachusetts i say
ours if i'm gonna make money any money
off it
not at all kids like this is
pre-existing i.p so it's not like i'm
like hey man where's my
taste of the figures they're like we
were making figures with or without you
you know so
not uh but they're when i say our it's
the pride of
our series masters of universe
revelation which
um there will be news on very very soon
just to here how do i put this without
spoiling things
within the netflix publicity department
um wheels already turning like i
did a long interview for the what we
used to call the epk the electronic
press kit
um but a breakdown of the history of how
we got
to the show that we made and um you know
like who was involved
the listing writers listening the cast
all the stuff and talking about the
experience of making it
um and then uh they showed me a
selection
of like for lack of a better description
stills let's call them friends like of
key moments and characters and stuff and
this will be the first time anyone has
seen them so you know it's we're getting
close to
revelation having its revelation kids
for anyone who's just like where is this
damn thing it's
it's it's ready and and now the
wheels are turning to let everyone know
that it's it's coming it's kind of
thrilling to
watch the you know i'm not a part of the
marketing
machine and as much as i i can give them
assistance or help but
professionals doing it so it's very like
illuminating and fun
and like inspiring to watch profession
professionals decide on how to market it
and stuff
because that's what they do all day long
like when you [ __ ] see an ad or
watching netflix trial and you're like
oh my god i want to watch that
that's the marketing department first
before anything else right so
same thing here like i'm gonna get to
i've seen this
[ __ ] thing from infancy from from
inception right like i've been there
since i was like
oh this is what i would do from the
moment i was pitching
so i've been with it every stage of its
life
someone is going to be able to like just
like the powerhouse kids were like oh
you think you know the story
here and then they [ __ ] directed the
[ __ ] out of it and made it look even
better than what we wrote
i get to have another bite at that apple
with the marketing people where they
like
take you know our entire series and turn
it into like a minute and a half [ __ ]
trailer
that is so [ __ ] good it will make
even me want to watch it
and i've seen this thing a zillion times
already
so it's about to begin the world's about
to know about
about masters of the universe revelation
and while that's happening i i'm i you
know what that's enough that's all i'll
say for now
um all right shall we talk about the
the topic at hand um feels like we
should
who better um falcon and the winter
soldier
kids uh of course happened on disney
plus
on thursday uh night i keep almost
wanting to go like my joint and then i
forget
about facebook hello to the facebook
folks
um you're keeping the man yeah what the
[ __ ]
yeah um will wilkins is taking care of
them the way that jc takes care of the
chat people here and stuff
but i keep forgetting that like you
can't do that um
falcon in the winter soldier uh happened
on thursday night i watched it on
friday uh with my wife who is [ __ ] in
and it's not uh it's not like you know
uh
surprising that she's in like you know
wanda vision took a bit of a commitment
because
the black and white sit commie of it all
and like just hold on
i swear it's going somewhere this
like hits like an action movie hard from
the [ __ ]
moment show open so you don't have to
sell this
like it she's watched all the movies now
so she knows the characters and stuff
but she's like dialed in and again it's
not
well i guess it is it's it's because
marvel knows what they're doing
like they kept her in their storytelling
[ __ ] web and then
so episode two we get to learn a little
more
uh jc did you ever create a a graphic
for zemo watch
i didn't get it i didn't get it done
this week are you [ __ ] kidding me
the only thing we needed
i'm sorry imagine imagine right now kids
a [ __ ] spinning graphic
was popping up fox news style and
[ __ ] told you
zemo watch and then underneath there was
a ticker
yeah with emo facts and if we could get
the music from the cbs
um evening movie that like dude
zero watch i i do have a good excuse
what don't bring up the baby she's gonna
derail the conversation a little bit
we're opening scum and villainy
oh [ __ ] well that is great news when uh
we're going to do a uh
fourth birthday bash on
april 6th so that's four years to the
day we originally opened
so it's kind of like we got blipped out
for our
third year and then we're coming back
for the fourth year
um are you calling it you better call
the blip party or something like that oh
i didn't even think about that but now
i'm going to update it
marketing they don't own the word blip
they just pop your ride
uh so we have tickets for that um on
sale right now if you're
in los angeles or headed to los angeles
um where do they buy those tickets i'll
i'll drop a link in the chat
you don't know it offhand it's long
eventbrite
dash slash e scum and villainy's first
fourth birthday bash and then a whole
bunch of numbers
you never heard a tiny earl or anything
like that you know what
i actually uh he's sitting right over
there
look he's in the bar hey tiny earl help
jc would you
i'm honored i have um i have
uh hired managers to run the bar
now so
that's right i'm acting surprised but i
knew that that's right jc
is so busy in his day job um that he has
hired some folks to run the bar how do
you feel about that champ
um it's weird it's crazy that's you like
you got
it's like you might as well hand over
your baby to somebody else to raise as
well
yeah it's weird um but because i am
raising a baby
i think it's
yes somebody's gotta figure out when
tummy time is yeah
yeah yeah tell them that's true
so anybody who follows me on twitter saw
this
um but uh i
kevin was texting mark and i in the
group chat for the show
and uh and checking in because
you know snyder vs hate and uh
my baby hit the siri button on my apple
watch
and i was talking to her as we were
going into the nursery
and i said it's okay you don't you don't
uh
you don't have to take a nap right now
we can do tummy time instead if you want
which sent to kevin and mark and mark's
like yeah man
i could use some tummy time right now
i want tummy time but it the exact
perfect response to hey you holding up
after all the snyder schneiderlin
yeah you wanna do some tummy time guys
yeah man give me some of that
sweet sweet tummy time i can't find it
yeah well because you did a screenshot
of it jc and then put it up on twitter
and then i retweeted that because it did
make me laugh
it is exactly as he said it happened um
so adorable and it's also speaking of
birthdays uh
you and i have been working for with
each other for a decade
as of thursday that is uh
absolutely correct jc put it up online
what was the
you answered a call to arms right jordan
was like you need somebody to shoot
the show up at the lovitz yeah you sent
a tweet and it was like hey any film
students
have a 5d and want to shoot uh the show
at the lovitz tonight and i was like
well i can pretend to be a film student
uh so i replied and uh
and you sent me you weren't i've for 10
years i thought you were a film school
student
but it was uh it was jay's it was jay
and bob get old it was jay's one year
sober birthday show oh [ __ ] a man wow
that's right coming up on 11 years for
him how long ago it was
um that is nuts 10 years look at all
we've done together
and you've been with us through uh every
incarnation of
of uh fat man on batman fam and beyond
that's involved
images and um
yeah like i started you were touring red
state
when i started that's how long ago it
was which is crazy to think about
that was 10 years ago i guess you're
right that's nuts man
um well thank you of course for a decade
of [ __ ]
uh and putting me capturing my image and
[ __ ] some of my
you know i when you do the show kids
you know generally you're in the moment
and you know you'll think about the show
right afterwards because you're like
what what worked what didn't blah blah
but you don't really like revisit it or
get to revisit it
thanks to jc i could revisit it i used
to love watching [ __ ] um
the old babylon anything that we shot at
beloveds because now that does feel like
a lifetime ago
and i'm glad that like you were rolling
cameras on a bunch of it
because um you know like that's
that that not only did we build a
business like off of babylon and jay and
sam bob get old but
it didn't begin like that it wasn't like
oh my god this is viable we can keep
doing this
it began because they were just fun to
do or
in jay's case therapeutic to do so the
fact that you know we were able to turn
it into
um something that we could also earn a
living off of particularly
jason and stuff um was everything and
and you shooting it all the early stuff
and then right up until [ __ ] now
making sure me and mark get fed out to
everybody
every week and even prior to that like
giving us a place to do the show with
the cantina which like made the show
changed the show you know gave it a
brand new dynamic
and has really defined what the show
is you know this this show has evolved
over the years
and it's now kind of it was defined by
the canteen it was redefined by
pandemic but you were involved in both
redefinitions so
thank you for that sir oh thank you it's
i mean i've gotten to travel the world
with you
how awesome is that that's true
yeah we made some flicks and [ __ ]
sounds good all right i'm i'm i'm gonna
everybody wants to hear
falcon winter soldiers yeah everyone in
chat's like shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] yourself
um you league go ahead i love it but you
lead
yeah no i i i continue to be impressed
by the show
you know on both two scales right the
first scale is
am i getting what i thought i was going
to get every week which is ultimately
lethal weapon right it's like
kind of two bickering friends kind of
friends allies kind of allies
giant action set pieces which it seems
like we're gonna get one
impossible sequence a week this week it
was the double trucks right
yeah which you know is is it hitherto
almost impossible scene to imagine on
television
um for how much effects i mean the time
it takes to shoot something like that
is what is why it never appears on tv
for context for context kids when you
watch a cw
show and they have a big action sequence
uh let's say two days
max for the action sequence and it's
generally not that
it's about a half a day you know and
they bring the stunt people in
and and stunt coordinators and and
pre-do it you could kind of see a
version of it they pre-visit for you and
shoot
shoot and show you like what they're
going for because time is of the essence
because you only have eight nine days
total to shoot that episode of a tv show
then you're done like you can't go over
because these things are
budgeted within an inch of their lives
and stuff and they got to make another
one in 10 minutes
so the action sequences on tv shows
episodic tv shows
you know tend to be not as grandiose as
the ones in the movies
marvel has made this commitment to like
okay we'll do tv
but basically we're just making one
giant movie and chopping it up
so same things you like about those big
movies we make
we're not going to reduce that like you
know they as much as
this is no insult to agents of shield by
any stretch of the imagination but
they had a budget like every episode was
like you guys got to come in at like
four to six whatever they [ __ ] gave
them
and you know like you have your big set
the one big one
[ __ ] write as many scenes for that as
you can clearly
with both wand division and now
especially with falcon and the winter
soldier
they're like that sequence with the
trucks probably took a week to shoot
yeah and that's a week that they would
have spent making
an entire episode of a normal hour-long
tv program or something like that yeah
like prior to this stuff
game of thrones was the anomaly right
where we're gonna spend
20 days shooting the battle of the
bastards you're going to spend
50 days shooting the the siege on
winterfell but mark
that wasn't tv that was hbo
i've heard that before no i'm pointing
that phrase
right the [ __ ] now great moment myself
um yeah we expect that kind of [ __ ]
from like game of thrones you know like
with the dragons for christ's sakes
yeah but and even they porcelain that
[ __ ] out like you didn't get that every
episode you got that like once maybe
twice a season
now we're getting this every episode by
the by the looks of it which is insane
to imagine
so it's thoroughly delighting on that
level of the buddy cop
version of it of the we're going to get
the whiz-bang of action stuff we're
going to get some really good dialogue
and you know
between these two actors and these two
characters that you love i mean
listening to them talk about you know
the big three
you know aliens wizards and robots and
just the the bigger banter between them
and then being able to dig deeper into
that stuff aliens
androids and wizards my bad
i mistook androids for robots um
i don't after seeing what you went
through on twitter
for you know the your opinions on zack
snyder's justice league i just want to
make sure you're bulletproof
i appreciate that i appreciate the
wrapping me in bubble wrap
just to make sure check in with mark
this week going
you're right buddy
mark was like you know you just you know
it's a trouble if it wasn't happening
but
you can't expect to you know have an
opinion and and not have somebody have
an opinion on top of it
yeah it's uh you know if you play long
enough in the pros you're gonna get hit
so that's that's totally fine um
but i think the thing that i'm i
continue to be impressed by is that
the show is also telling a different
story which seems to be fundamentally
can a black man be captain america you
know and
and a what it means to be a black man in
this particular universe
and and the potential and possibility
that you know sam doesn't want the
shield why doesn't he want the shield
what what in him is
is is resisting being captain america we
get to meet a character
who has been in comics sporadically here
and there
but is so close to my heart of isaiah
bradley
isaiah bradley dude the moment they were
in the neighborhood the moment they said
baltimore maryland i was like what are
we doing now are we gonna do this and
then as soon as the kid answered the
door
and he said you know even before he said
it i said to my wife isaiah
i said isaiah bradley and he says isaiah
and i was like
this is for those that don't follow
comics very closely
under joe quesada's stewardship at
marvel
um who was it um it was called baker
well karl baker on our but robert
morales i think yeah
on on the story it was called truth
yeah three-parter red white and blue and
it told the story of
before there was a captain america
before steve rogers
they tested the super soldiers serum on
somebody else
an african-american named isaiah bradley
who
was as the they called him in the comics
the black captain america
now this was not a part of like you know
ancient marvel history
this was a wonderful [ __ ] retcon that
sounds like it would have been done
like today sound so finger on the pulse
that's why
them doing it in this show is absolutely
brilliant in the wake of what the
watchman was able to accomplish
in the wake of black lives matter last
year doing this storyline
is an absolute no-brainer and i take my
[ __ ]
moose my cow cap off to the good folks
who decided like yes we could totally do
this now
but let me take you back to when they
originally did this story
like it was pretty groundbreaking and
also like
bold for marvel to be like uh we're
going to
tell a story about how our universe
left somebody behind like how the the
original sin
of the marvel universe um beautiful book
bold and beautiful kyle baker an amazing
[ __ ] artist and then i guess like
throughout the years they've pulled
him in to the mythologies of marvel at
large
like and then he's got the was it the
grandson
who's uh patriots yes in uh young
avengers
and young avengers so when he when they
first did that book
it was it was groundbreaking and
controversial
but i fell out of comics and i didn't
realize that they
kept weaving him in which is so [ __ ]
smart because now
you debut this [ __ ] character for the
world and
like most of the people who have never
heard of this character
are [ __ ] intrigued beyond belief the
same way that sam was like
what do you mean there was a there was a
black hero and nobody
[ __ ] told me after all this time and
[ __ ] so once this is all done
you could [ __ ] make an entire isaiah
bradley
series like and you know
obviously it wouldn't be carl lumley who
was amazing in the episode
but like you could [ __ ] just fight
you got
yourself a younger young carl lumbly and
you [ __ ] go nuts you [ __ ] tell
stories said in world war [ __ ] two
with black captain america beating nazi
ass who the [ __ ] wouldn't watch that
show
yeah i mean it's such a great retcon you
know and
and the idea this sort of central idea
which is a 100 inspired by stuff like
the tuskegee experiment
was there's no way that in 1943
the first person who gets this
experimental radical syndrome
is a blond-haired blue-eyed white guy
like it 100 would have been a black
person who would have gotten it and made
sure he didn't die
first and so then given the way that
even the army treated steve rogers first
as a show pony like
you're not getting to go into war you
are not disposable to us
to to them isaiah bradley was 100
disposable like yeah it worked
but we also are never going to parade
you in front of people so you get to do
the [ __ ] that steve rogers wanted to do
and we didn't let him
like he got to be [ __ ] black ops he
got to go behind enemy lines he got to
do the awful business of war
um in a real way and then was forgotten
and then was sort of cast aside
and left to his own devices to in many
ways like
age poorly you know no [ __ ] pension
like
now like i'm one of america's greatest
heroes that nobody knows about is living
in a tiny house in baltimore
and so they get to talk about all this
stuff and to put it on the stage
and for real and make it not just
subtext but text
yes and then to wrap it with scenes of
you know what it is now like
for a black man in the army today like
oh you're totally gonna get pulled over
and you know potentially arrested simply
because you're in the wrong place at the
wrong time
you know and then dealing with that in
the scene with him talking to bucky in
the neighborhood
yeah that was a bold scene like if you
had just done that scene and hadn't even
touched the isaiah bradley
storyline that it looks like they're now
going to mine
deeply um which means they probably will
have flashbacks
to young isaiah in action like no way
they they just let i mean carl lumley is
an amazing actor
and a wonderful monologist but there's
no way they just let him tell the story
without [ __ ]
flashing back we see the money they're
spending on the show
i mean they haven't tipped it in any of
the
spots any of the trailers but that might
be because they were trying to keep
the isaiah storyline quiet um
but like it's it's it would have been
enough if they had just done that scene
on the street
like if they'd left out isaiah but
they're going for it man
in a big bad way and and like they're
also
i feel telling a compelling story with
[ __ ] john walker as well
where i'm like oh [ __ ] like you know
just like everybody else
with that last shot in the first episode
you're like that ain't steve rogers
but for them to bring him in in the
first scene and kind of give you the
background
and then the kind of new the good
morning america news report that kind of
detailed
you know who he is and whatnot and then
to show him at work
like you know you start warming up to
the character and you start to see like
you know he's with our heroes he's there
he wants to help he wants them
involved although he does have that kind
of like
you know be i need cap's wingman like he
wants
them under him like so does you know
like yeah he wants to be the captain
he's the captain yeah i guess and it was
so small one moment too where he goes
like
where he's like just then stay out of my
way or don't get in my way
yeah that you know in the comics we know
you know john walker was
you know i don't want to spoil [ __ ] for
the show but he wasn't like
the on the up and up at all times
instead
um but they brought in [ __ ] battle
star as well
yeah i love the like the weird kind of
marketing approved sidekick version of
this which is like listen
we are totally because cap had falcon so
if you're going to be the new camp you
need your own version of falcon we got
to find you a black sidekick man
like because you can't just do this any
other way it's what worked before it's
what works again and so this poor guy is
like
i got to be battle star and i love the
look on bucky's face and he's like
nope not doing this like another [ __ ]
nickname
i think battle star is definitely more
like bucky
inspired particularly the suit so like
because the whole time bucky's looking
at him like he is kind of like
so you're a young me um it's a fun
concept too
about like yeah these this ip
of captain america is owned by the us
government like it's not you know you
know
bruce wayne nobody knows that bruce
wayne's batman but batman owns batman
bruce wayne owns batman
even if steve rogers was alive and was
like you know i don't want
i want to keep being captain america
they could always been like no we're
going to give it to this other person
like it's a it's a it's a like a [ __ ]
company mascot for heaven's sakes
yeah it's like you don't own america mr
rogers that's ours
um i love seeing them all fight on top
of the trucks
particularly when they when you usage
well i keep wanting to call them usage
particularly when john walker and um
um battle start what is it lamar hanks
um when they show up on the [ __ ]
helicopter
that was such a comic book moment where
it's just like they arrived just a time
to help
i also love that he [ __ ] used a gun
as well
yes yeah i thought that was really cool
and really telling as well because
how often do you remember steve rogers
[ __ ] pulling a gun
yeah i mean he he did he did quite a bit
in
the first avenger because he's a [ __ ]
soldier and that's what you do
he does a little bit in avengers which i
watched the other day by accident you
know when he like
you know he's got a gun shooting at the
at the loki pokey stick
you know agent dudes but beyond that
like yeah he's not missed a gun he's i
got a giant shield and i'm gonna whale
it into your face and i'm way better at
this than i am at that
um the thing that i'm so excited about
and
you know this is probably a minor
spoiler unless you've read the book
um you know truth read white and blue
but
the idea which seems to be still holding
in this version
that steve rogers knew nothing about
isaiah bradley but then at some point
gets that information and gets told and
is furious
like there is a hundred percent a
version of this show
where we know that steve rogers we know
that chris evans
has signed on to appear as captain
america steve rogers don't give people
don't give [ __ ] people's hopes up now
i'm giving myself [ __ ] hopes up that
there's going to be a secret let's
declare this
we know nothing we don't know anybody
speculation at best
speculate away that you get a scene
in the last episode with with chris
evans and old man makeup showing up in
baltimore
and like getting the real download from
isaiah bradley like
tell me the truth you know which then
can send you on a completely different
tech
with steve rogers now he's furious of
the american government for what they
did and what they didn't tell him
and how they you know fundamentally
betrayed the tenets of the america that
he knows
by turning this man into into a guinea
pig and then not rewarding him for it
you know like i just that collision that
that war of ideologies
and in this version he mentions he's
like they put me in jail
for 30 years that's not something i
remember from the other story
so you know it when he said it it hit my
ear and
i was like what like i remember that but
it makes sense
like whether like he says they put me in
jail they
pull you know came in and pulled my
blood all the time and stuff so they
would guinea pig
or for decades it sounds like um
i mean it's just such great storytelling
material
yeah it's so rich how many episodes i
got four left
i think they got four left it's funny i
remember um
like a year ago my reps you know were
trying to set me up
for a meeting in marvel they're like hey
man do you want to like where do you
want to go meet i'm like i want to meet
at [ __ ] marvel like i want to get a
marvel job
yeah no dummy and they're like well what
story would you want to tell like what
what do they have lying around that you
won't want to get into and i was like i
want to do
truth i want to do the isaiah bradley
story and
uh and then i was told they're like yeah
that's not on the table anymore
and i was like huh i wonder why and then
i saw that carl lumley was cast
for you know falcon winter soldiers like
are they doing today bradley is that why
they just shut down the
the door so hard on that idea and that's
100 why they shut down the door on that
idea because they're getting into it
which i'm so [ __ ] excited like
wish it could have been me i'm so glad
that it exists
uh who is doing the show who's running
the shows
malcolm spellman is the sort of head
writer show runner
in whatever weird marvel nomenclature
now exists where as we
heard a couple weeks ago you know
caravan feige is the
the overall you know end-all be-all
naturally it's marvel that's his thing
and then on one of vision jack schaefer
was the quarterback head writer and on
this one
malcolm spellman is that guy and uh and
he's
he's a deep veteran at this stuff like
he's been working in tv for 20 some odd
years and
is bringing the high heat you know like
this is the i get to play with this
this world these characters on this
budget
like hell yes you're getting all of it
and you're getting like really sweet
like deep scenes where like you know the
the revelation that bucky has
been hanging his entire kind of moral
persona on the fact that like
steve believed that i was good and he
believed that you were captain america
and if one of them isn't true then both
of them aren't true
and so i need you to be captain america
otherwise where the hell am i
you know like that that sort of deep
psychoanalysis of this character
is just kiss absolute jeff's kiss
it is uh i i thought they launched
strong
and i'll be honest going into this you
know for me it was the baron zemo show
where i'm like i'm here for zemo
no [ __ ] emo me i'm on zemo watch but
the moment they [ __ ] went in the
isaiah bradley direction i was like
you know once again like it sounds corny
and i know everyone makes fun of me for
it and [ __ ] like that but i get so
incredibly emotional my eyes glassed up
because i'm
like it's just like it makes me
so [ __ ] happy like you know where i'm
like
i i know just enough about what's going
on
you know to not be lost but i don't know
in which direction they're gonna take
all these
characters like i know the toys i've
seen all the toys i've seen other people
play with them
the way these cats play with the toys i
don't i may know the toys
but i don't know the direction they're
taking the story the fact that they're
even like taking a step in that
direction
is just beyond bold and beautiful and
they're going to get [ __ ] rewarded
for it you know what i'm saying like
it's not like what a risk
like [ __ ] who ain't gonna enjoy this
story people
enjoyed it in comic books you know
forever now that they've got the world
stage with these marvel movies and and
this
and the disney plus shows why not mine
that incredible material
incredibly timely man like finger on the
pulse
and tell a compelling [ __ ] story that
like it doesn't look like any other
story that they told before
that's what this company has been
excellent at like
past iron man 2 and thor 2 the dark
world they stopped making sequels
and everything is pushing the story to
another story
they're not content to just give you the
thing you had you could say like yeah
well doctor strange is an awful lot like
iron man sure there's similarities with
all these [ __ ] characters man or
superheroes but
you gotta give them [ __ ] credit like
these cats are
really like you know they can play it
safe and just do the same
play the same song for the next 10 years
and we'd all listen and dance
but they're willing to be like no the
story's here now
now the [ __ ] story's over here now
the story's going out there and the
whole time
while we're enjoying the [ __ ] show
right in front of us the great and
secret show
is clearly the young avengers are being
built
clearly yeah and i like that they're
using
the tv stuff to wrestle with
sort of real human social issues
in ways that they haven't been doing
with the movies for good reason you have
two hours
and we have our mandate here and yes we
will advance some story and we'll deal
with some [ __ ] whatever
historically people don't go to those
movies because they're like i want to
think
you know they're like [ __ ] show me
the the [ __ ] theme park
scorsese like the theme park movies you
know traditionally
marvel's very good at character stuff as
we've learned but like
you know a lot of people are there
because at base
you just want to see people in costumes
you want to see comic books [ __ ]
so they have as you're saying a platform
now where they're like
well we got time so let's give them the
whiz-bang
but what if we just really started like
marvelizing these characters getting
into their heads their hearts
their lives how they interact with the
world how the world interacts with them
like you know issues like
grief um clearly we're seeing race
uh coming up in falcon in the winter
soldier
um who i mean you know loki looks like
a fun time jumping series who knows what
the depth is going to be there
yeah you know and it's a thing that you
know a spirit that seems carried over
from the netflix marvel shows
where at least three of the four of
those was about something
you know jessica jones was about ptsd
you know daredevil was about
guilt you know luke cage similarly was
also about race you know punisher
eventually got to be about
um sort of uh you know revenge but not
the simple sort of the price of revenge
on your own personal life
iron fist was about whatever the [ __ ]
that was going to be but who the hell
now's fist was about
five episodes too long fair enough
um but so to see that kind of spirit be
brought over to these marvel shows i
know each one of these is gonna be about
something
is really encouraging because yeah like
you want that
you want more meat on those bones to dig
into
while still getting the the the
fireworks that you get from a moral
production it's really nice to see them
just kind of stretch
and grow and not be simple they could
have just been
you know yeah we'll do this it'll just
be you know super fun but longer
but no they decided that they wanted to
make these about something and that's
really encouraging
um they're smart to do this too because
you're gonna there's a whole world of
merchandise is gonna open up with
uh isaiah bradley's stuff are you
kidding me
like untouched you know maybe graffiti
designs might have done some
t-shirts back in the day you know uh of
the
kyle baker artwork but man that's an
untapped
vein that they're going to like be able
to market
and sell put on a t-shirt because it's a
brand new concept to some people old to
those of us who've been reading comics
but like
it's marketable as [ __ ] heck man um i
would not surprise me
eli yeah it would not surprise me at all
if you go from falcon winter soldier
season one to captain america truth
which is sort of in between and then
falcon winter soldier season two
in a year or two yeah they could
literally just do [ __ ] truth as a
miniseries they could like
do that's amazing god i'm happy for him
i'm
happier for me as an audience member
because i'm like this is [ __ ]
dazzling like
now i'm [ __ ] i'm in like crazy you
know all the way up to episode one
i was like well you know i'll watch it
it's [ __ ] marvel but like you know
am i are these the two characters that
i'm [ __ ] there for
but now i'm there for it like
you know it ain't necessarily the
characters that have [ __ ] grabbed me
as much as the storytelling using the
characters
um so yeah i'm i you know now i'm in
that place where
when this started i was like yeah i
don't care if it comes out once a week
now i'm like [ __ ]
why can't we do more and these things
aren't going anywhere like the falcon
winter soldier season premiere
was the most watched season series
premiere
on disney plus um higher than
mando higher than than wanda vision um
because it's riding on the wave of those
two things
season two of the mandalorian they're
also up to 100 million subscribers as
well whereas
when they started mando they didn't even
have 100 million i don't even know if
they had 50 at that point mando
helped get them up there one division
helped get him up there so
yeah falcon the winter soldier i ain't
saying like oh they're just doing it on
the backs of those things but
they do get to enter the stage with a
[ __ ]
huge number of people already on the
platform
and since they all loved what marvel did
with
you had those cats but also it's like
some cats probably wouldn't have even
gone for one division right some cats
are like i like the action [ __ ]
[ __ ] falcon the winter soldier it
looks like a james bond movie on tv
um yeah so it's it's incredibly
promising
and it seems disney plus is going
nowhere anytime soon
because they just keep jumping from
strength to strength to strength and
later on
uh i feel after we talked to our our
guest for the
for the evening we'll get into the other
strengths that disney plus
plus is moving into you're absolutely
right all right kids there's our
our recap review of uh falcon and the
winter soldier episode two if you
haven't seen it yet
spoilers sorry i should have said that
up front yes um but if you haven't seen
it yet come on why the [ __ ] are you
paying that much money for disney plus
you don't watch it on day one
get the to a watchery and it's sunday
for heaven's sakes you got no excuse i
can know some people like i got a job
you [ __ ] prick i'm like i got you but
saturday and sunday and also like what
are you doing after the job
sex it's not nearly as good as this
falcon in the winter soldier show i'll
tell you that
you know what makes sex better while
watching a falcon winter soldier
i don't wanna i don't wanna be
distracted by sex i just wanna
put all that money on that screen i just
wanna count the dollars
as minute by minute goes by just like oh
look at
all the money man but unlike sometimes
you look at a big expensive movie or
whatever the [ __ ] you know like look at
all the money
why did they bother this you're like
what money [ __ ] well spent
every penny they spent on the show is
money well spent not just because it's
like
oh they made a really great show they're
minting the future
like the smartest [ __ ] thing in the
world they did was bring isaiah bradley
into this world man they're going to
make
so much money off this concept they're
going to tell so many new stories of
this concept
they are going to make so many people
happy
just by exploiting this concept that
they've had sitting in their treasure
trove of others
but it's not a story that generally a
lot of this [ __ ] you got to be like
thank you stan jack steve this
is not this is you're thanking robert
morales and
and and kyle baker and not like you know
they come up with this in the 60s
this happened in your lifetime kids yeah
this was like
early 2000s if i remember correctly um
so yeah and it's it's the like like we
talked about before the idea of
finding a pocket within the the ongoing
continuity of the narrative
that exists to just tell a new story
without at all
disrupting the old story you know in
fact adding more shades and more color
to it you know
the idea that that that there was a
price to be paid by other people
for the creation of steve rogers and the
fact that he didn't know it
um and so he his his the advantage that
he had
was that he didn't understand the price
that was paid
um i think that's such great
storytelling and it just opens up so
many avenues for even more so yeah i'm
super happy that uh that feige
and malcolm spellman and the entire
branches of marvel decided like yeah no
let's tell this story
this is the perfect story for us to tell
period but even better at the moment
um right now let's get into it i gotta
wonder
ma'am what is going to be the hook
of of loki
yeah i mean if i had to guess
and again purely just a guess but it
seems like loki's
biggest the the core wound of loki is
that he's been abandoned
to a certain degree like you know
familial connections are not there for
him and it's his own fault
and so if you could travel through time
and if you could do anything
like maybe you fix those things maybe
you you fix
all of the the relationships that you
found a way to damage over the years
you know so that you can actually have a
family again so that you're not just the
adopted brother that nobody wants
but that you're the the beloved son that
everybody loves and
maybe time travel is the key to that and
of course time travel will ultimately be
you know the the the the spine the
splinter
that cuts against everything and makes
it impossible because you can't just
fix love with magic but even still like
to watch him try
might be fun um that should be the
tagline you can't fix love with magic
or eleven thunder coming soon um all
right
kids don't forget go watch [ __ ]
falcon and the winter soldier we'll be
reviewing
the next there's only four more episodes
right they're only doing
wow man i mean they're getting a lot
done first episode was like 45 minutes
this episode of 45 minutes we've seen 90
minutes of a
of a movie already we haven't met the
big bad guy yet
that's true yeah we saw a tail end on
our zemo watch which [ __ ] jc
lazy-ass kid get around to because he's
so selfish taking care of his
little baby um zemo watch
i'll tell you i was on zemo watch and
now not so much because now i'm on
isaiah watch because i'm like i had no
idea where we were going here man i
expected zemo can i
um can i redeem my my zemo watch fail
please did you guys pick up that the
cell
number was two one eight seven
which we know because it's the same cell
that princess leia was held in on the
death star
get out of here so there's a little zeno
easter egg
that's nice that is nice we did get our
first taste of
zemo maskless emo which is still zemo
more or less
um daniel bruhl pops up in the last shot
of the show
um and uh that means you know we've seen
trailers for this show
and so we see him in the mask and we see
him not in jail so clearly
something's going to happen i don't
think that's a spoiler anybody that's
seen the trailer
kind of figured that out but yeah in
zemo watch world we finally got our
first taste of zemo but
uh that was usurped by uh
thirst for isaiah bradley do you think
they go back in next episode or they
wait an episode
um you know i don't know i don't i don't
know how much
isaiah bradley we're going to see sam
looked back at the house
man you know there was that moment where
he like wanted to go back in
you know because i feel like there's the
you know we have to deal with the crisis
at hand
but by the time that [ __ ] is done like
here's a here's a a
a tail end here's a loose end that i
gotta go tie up which is what the hell
did they do to this poor man
and uh and how can we make it better how
can we make that right
we met our uh not our big bad but our
mini bad
who isn't maybe so bad um
the whether carrie what was her name
carrie
you know carly something um
who apparently is also a super soldier
um
this is lousy with super soldiers now i
know but the the idea of the story
behind those flag smashers though is
that
when everyone came back from the blip a
lot of people were displaced to created
um um what is it
um what's it called when a bunch of
people are displaced and
refugees yes created a bunch of refugees
and apparently that
medicine they're stealing is to take to
these refugee camps all around the world
or whatever
i'm like once again they're getting a
lot of mileage out of that blip man
out of a snap like crazy how both of
these series
i mean i guess it's not that crazy we
are in the wake of end game
but so far both of these series have
dealt with the repercussions
of something that we all celebrated as a
heroic act
yeah and i think it's the blip is is
serving for them
better than um sokovia did
you know because sokovia felt like an
abstract thing
it's like yes no for sure people died
there including t'chaka and we get
you know all of that but um the sokovian
accords
and like all of those things always felt
kind of
squishy as far as as a real
kind of pre and post condition
to have people responding to whereas the
blip they're they're squeezing real
trauma
and real empathy and real emotion out of
it in the way that they really could
with the sokovia accords uh marvel
killing it killing it it's been a great
month for watching
superhero [ __ ] man um okay
speaking of superhero [ __ ] our
long-waiting
guest man who had to sit through us
talking about [ __ ]
uh is here to talk to us uh ladies and
gentlemen you have seen
if you're watching this show which is on
youtube certainly somewhere over the
years
you've seen one of the many bat in the
sun uh productions the latest one was
called dying is easy
instantly uh went viral got millions of
[ __ ] hits
these are the batman flicks that you
watch
on youtube and you're like why does this
look so amazing why can't the batman
have to look like that
in a real movie oh my god is batman
fighting [ __ ] predator and [ __ ] like
that right
it's it's incredible
what they've been able to accomplish and
so i was shooting what was i
shooting um oh uh my
storybots uh appearance uh
for next year so we went to a little
stage uh to shoot cause they got like a
two-person crew
uh and as i was leaving i got approached
uh by
aaron and aaron was like hey man we do
bat in the sun and i met
a dude who like came over and was and
started telling me
a story so i guess it's the dude who
plays batman
a lot um and he's played batman at cons
and stuff like that and i think he's
worked in
in aaron's stuff and so he
starts telling me this story he's like
you're never going to remember this he's
going but years ago
i was at comic con and there was a you
know a little kid who wanted to take a
picture and then they were like oh
batman's
taking a break because i was gonna go
back and grab a smoke or whatever
grab something it's like but uh
like i heard somebody like say
her name and her name was harley
and so i you know stopped because of the
batman connection and i
came back and took a picture with her
and stuff and she was so polite
and i said i know exactly who you are
you were dressed like
batman like the alex ross batman and you
were with a wonder woman who looked like
the alex ross wondering he's like yes
and i was like that picture is in our
house like ever since the [ __ ]
picture was taken
it's been somewhere in our house there's
always been that picture of little
harley at the con
with alex ross batman and alex ross like
wonder woman stuff so
he seemed rather like you remember that
i was like remember it like
it's like it happened [ __ ] yesterday
for me because it's
preserved in a [ __ ] image so um
aaron shonky is the guy who does
the bat in the sun productions he was
there and i was like you could come on
[ __ ]
fat man on batman talk about and so you
know
he's been very sweet about waiting
because batman dying is easy dropped
like two weeks ago but then we had
kirkman last week and we had um
any park the week before that and then
matt shackman week before that
but uh making his fat man uh beyond
debut ladies and gentlemen uh the mind
behind bat in the sun
uh give it up for aaron shawnke
aaron you there you're there hey what's
going on guys glad to be here
thank you patient [ __ ] thank you
for waiting through all that
and stuff um talk about uh dying is easy
real quick give these cats
whip out your bat dick and hit them with
your numbers man
how many people watched it so far uh we
had about four million people watch it
in the first week it was it was all over
the place it was it's our highest rated
video is like a
like a 99.6 rating on youtube so it's
been great it's wound up on the
hollywood reporter and all these
big places so we've been really excited
and just uh
proud of how well it's done how well
it's been received because that's always
the tricky thing because fans can be
really intense and they've
loved it and it's just been really great
to see something that we've worked on
for a long time
put a lot of money into the received as
well as it has
now take us back to the beginning man
was it was batman dead end the first one
no that was that was uh we did uh a
different one at the time that's right
around the time when we kind of started
making films that's about 18 years ago
but what about i think 18 years ago
right about 18 yeah
yeah i've been a while yes 2003 i know
crazy
right where did it begin what was the
first one uh we did
um the big one that really hit i think
was a batman legends and i remember you
actually
uh tweeted on that like years ago um
i remember you you we posted it and we
just this is like right when youtube
first came out like we were just making
stuff we worked
in hollywood for a while and we were
like let's just make some stuff put on
this new thing called youtube
and we made this batman legends which
was like just a series of cool action
shots
and uh and i actually you were like one
i think the first person to uh the tweet
about it even like when
twitter was just coming out you're like
i got my lotion and my dick in hand i'm
ready to watch this and i was like
it was like all right you know so it was
pretty cool and from there just
it took off and we kind of learned what
youtube was and then
we just made a lot of videos and they've
gotten recognition from a lot of people
we've ended up working with
lionsgate and savon and hasra all
because of this and
dc and different things so it's been a
great ride and
we have you know just keep keep riding
that wave you know what was
and what's the versus show that you guys
do so that that's super power beat down
and that's where we take two different
uh
super powered uh characters and make
them battle
which is something that you know i grew
up in comic shops and uh
and that's something we all talk about
who would win this person or this person
that's always you know the age-old
debate um and then a bunch of us i was
on the show deadliest warrior which was
like 15 years ago and that
similar concept a lot of sun guys were
like let's just let's just you know me
and my dad had this idea to like let's
have superheroes battle and show it in a
really
cinematic way and we go to different
comic shops and conventions and
interview people and what do you think
and we have people vote online and then
we
and we've had batman vs darth vader
we've had spider-man vs darth maul
we've had we've done you know so we got
stan lee on the show for that so it's
been really great and
fans love it they get real intense about
it though because you know they
this character should have won this is
so wrong and it's like well
no one really lost it's all you know
fictional but fans love it they go crazy
for it so
it's been really cool i mean we've been
with superheroes and um
you know just for a long time doing that
sort of thing and then we ended up
kind of migrating into you know um dying
is easy which is more
storytelling which is actually what we
like more so that's really our fun thing
and we got kind of
getting to know for our action on
survivor vita but i think we actually
you did a thing on us when we did work
with valiant we did a feature film for
valiant comic books
and tiffany was on there so we ended up
working with valley and then like this
um
a series which was then turned into a
feature which was cool so
what is the uh like when i look at
what what always makes it stand out of
course is the attention to detail it's
like these were made by people who read
comic books
for a long time most of the adaptations
we ever saw
you know were made by people clearly
didn't understand or even read the
source material and stuff
um but a big part of what you guys do
which always catches the [ __ ] eye
is the attention to costume detail and
even on the super power beat town
like it's not that you just have oh
these two characters are fighting
they look like the best renditions
of these characters straight from the
comic page and
you know as we've seen in the marvel
movies and the dc movies they always
kind of do their impressions
of the characters and sometimes the
suits are way the [ __ ] off and sometimes
they don't look like the way you think
they look
but you guys stuff always looks like the
source material
and as a guy who makes [ __ ] for a living
like the first thing i always think when
i look at that is like this looks so
[ __ ] expensive is that the costly
part of the process
uh it is i mean we definitely put a lot
into it
and uh but like you said a lot of us are
fans you know so we all work
in the industry but then we all just
kind of donate our time it's like hey do
we want to
renovate our kitchen or make a badass
video and put it online i was like
that'd be way cooler so let's do that
um so it's definitely not cheap it's
definitely expensive but like
everyone comes in with their own you
know just love for the characters
and uh it's important that they're as
you said visually represented correctly
with their size and their movement
um a big thanks uh for our costumes who
like does our batman costumes is uh
reeves effects which i think you
actually i think he one of his cows and
he he
just like you find people that love
these characters so much and
when you work with them they they have
just such a uh
they're zoned into that character and
all the little nuances you know when
you're working with
uh you know the the length of the ears
or how the facial expression should be
and all these things so
um we reach out to a lot of um people
who understand the costumes and work
with it when we did one room and that
was all real
you know wrapped leather and stuff so um
oh yeah here's the
video that's a video playing there of uh
kevin porter wearing a reeves uh a suit
and then uh and we even redesigned
the bat it's interesting because we want
to kind of add our own our own taste to
it so you're like oh that's the bat in
the sun version like our our bat logo my
father redesigned so you go that's
the baton sun bat logo but still has the
iconic feel that you would that you
would really want
so but um have you ever gotten in
trouble that's the other thing that
always occurs to me like
in the with the first few were they like
hey you can't do that or
because it was youtube and wild wild
west
nobody gave a [ __ ] because it's not like
you guys are going we own this
obviously you put up the disclaimer
total fan film production and stuff
but was there ever like kickback from
warner brothers or somebody no they've
been really actually cool that
originally like got like 10 or 12 years
ago when fan films started coming on the
scene and they reached out to me and
they were like how can we start like
being involved they kind of want to do
what lucas did with creating this whole
like um
so they can monitor but encourage it um
that nothing ever really super came with
that just because
i guess of where uh i guess because
youtube took off and there was like
almost too many it was almost too hard
to mediate but
oners is a big fan they reached out i
worked with them they brought me to set
a lot
um you know trying to build a
relationship with them but they've been
a big fan we never sell any of it and
we're never disrespectful you know it's
not we're doing like a batman porn or
anything like that we try to show it
and they've they've actually said
they're like when um like the different
companies when we post stuff like oh our
sales went up
and even like we did a lot of power
ranger stuff and then saban and hasbro
worked out with us and we did a lot of
official stuff with them so
it's been a you know just try to it's
been a great like i said journey and try
to put
the best quality out there you're not
disrespecting the ip you know that's a
big one
when you guys i'm sorry go ahead okay
i'm just gonna say when you guys first
started
what was the hope that would come out of
this what were you like hey we're gonna
make these films and x will happen
you know and then did x happen for you
guys
uh i mean the main goal is to you know
work with the big studios to make the
and produce
and direct those big films and it's
definitely we've progressed like it's
when we first started
i started off as a stunt guy and we end
up making these these uh films and then
like they took notice and like i said
dc's reached out and
um worked with sony and worked with uh
like i said hasbro and all these people
have contacted us so it's afforded us
great opportunities
we've built a huge fan base um i've
gotten you know you base all the tools
you need an agent and all these things
have come to us because they can see
the you know quality that we do and so
it's been great
and we just recently uh did a
kickstarter and raised half a million
dollars
for original project uh called the white
dragon which is gonna uh start jason
david frank he was the
the main power ranger and um so we've
teamed up with him and we're doing this
uh
kind of dark uh superhero series with
him but
this whole ride is giving us you know
three million fans and they're so
fervent and they love us
so it's been great and just because i
think they resonate because they see
that we're the same you know it's never
like what would the fans want i'm like
we're the fans like i like well i have
to go out and buy a book
and learn about batman i was like i'll
just go to my closet i have like a
thousand
you know like that's how i live and read
that stuff so it's been really cool
you saying we really those attention to
details like in dining is easy like all
like all the arkham numbers on all the
the inmates or
the years of the characters were created
you know and like when bullock is
talking to uh
the woman on the radio that woman's
voice that's actually athena finger
who's the granddaughter of bill finger
you know the career so we want to we
want to put all these little things in
there the fans that were like oh that's
what that is you know to let them you
know
because every me and my dad put so much
attention to detail into every frame you
know that's but
it's something we basically make it like
i want to watch this like if i were to
go theaters i was like oh because then
we end up watching and i'm like
this is really good they should make a
sequel and i was like that
that decision would be our decision you
know so it's like it's kind of a fun
you know so it's really cool and it's
cool just seeing the fans get excited
about it so we're
really happy with where it is and we're
rolling out a lot of original projects
because we built this whole fan base and
they love us
so much now so like i said we have the
white dragon we have a kids animation a
book coming up called the space fares so
it's really cool
um they should be giving you guys an hbo
max series man
like that's that's we want fans started
a petition it has almost 15 000
signatures and
for a while aaron shonky for hbo max was
i guess trending on twitter or something
i'm not good with twitter but um
it was all there doing that stuff so
it's been it's been really cool it's
been really cool hopefully get some
meetings out of it and talk with them so
[ __ ] yeah i mean you've been boots on
the ground for a long time
like and and they're in a world where
they just keep doing
dcip like oh my god you you've been
doing it for years you've got experience
already
yeah yeah and it'd be really cool and
like so we worked in the industry a lot
i did all the motion capture for
spider-man and the games and
done a different stuff so like i i
understand that you know the industry
and worked in and it's just now we gotta
gotta marry the two you know two
together you do it with dad right
where's that yeah let me bring him in
here
bring my dad in here this is one of the
[ __ ] coolest things about
all of this is that bob and son get to
work together
sitting off screen over there listening
what's up captain
hey hello kevin hey mark hey
thank you so much for having us on the
show it's really awesome i appreciate it
this is a big deal
oh my god please it's a big deal for us
um when uh when you first started who
who had the idea for for just
making films or beat down or well he
he's a he's a
he's an artist throwing through a
renaissance guy he's a music composer a
sculptor artist
yeah um so he's big on to that so oh my
i get a lot of my artistic
from this guy i'm actually originally a
musician back when i was
lot of rock bands played a lot of rock
clubs here in la in the 80s and
recorded a lot of music so but from
there i just you know after aaron got in
high school you know he wanted to get
into film making
and uh he thought about film school and
then eventually
we just agreed why don't we just start
making films yeah and we just kind of
teamed up
and it was originally a beginning it was
just with like a vhs camera
but he learned from that and you know
and from there it just
evolved and one thing after another and
you know we've
progressed yeah it's been great
how weird like you made him that he made
films with you like doesn't that blow
your mind like whenever i work with my
kid on something and
she's i'm always like you came out of my
balls
you must be on set sometimes and just be
like oh my god i made a little best
friend
who i could make [ __ ] cool [ __ ] with
yeah well you're right i i do it's the
best thing about what i do is being able
to work with my son and you know
fans come at us all the time and they
say that all the time they go wow it's
so cool you get to work with your son
and they're right so i i really
appreciate
that i have here with him and we see eye
to eye and
you know it's um it's it's a great
working experience because we'll we'll
basically we um we work together we'll
hang out together when we're not making
movies we're watching
tom brady wins through bulls and we're
doing all kinds of fun stuff you know
we're always
just anything that we're doing it's been
a it's a great thing and um
just admire the hell out of his ability
yeah
so awesome a lot of it tends to be
like i wasn't one of these people but
most artists like i gotta get away from
my parents they don't get me mad
and like you know have to get out of
there it's the rare birds that are like
what do you mean like i i don't have to
get out of here i love these people and
[ __ ] look what we can accomplish
together
because you're right you know he was
never a problem he's always been like
right there
wanting to do what i want to do and be
creative and and
uh it's really made uh the whole
experience uh
not only fun but successful and that and
that really
resonates even like in everything we do
because of the close i'm really close to
my
my all my family my mom my grandma too
as well and uh and that resonates in the
bat in the sun because everyone is like
a family because they see
what we have because the figureheads are
like obviously close family and that
resonates everyone in there is
they said kevin who was your uh who was
the um
batman who took the photo with you
because yeah here in florida he was dc's
official
batman he wishes he could be here today
um a family emergency came up when he
couldn't but he really wishes that he
wanted to give you his best and he
hopes to connect with you but he's he's
family to us we've known him for
um we met kevin the same way that your
story when you uh
had harley take the picture with kevin
then but the first time we ever met
kevin was at the comic con
and we have it on a videotape of him
walking up there when he was nothing
like 14
15 15. yeah a long time ago this is
forever going and we just
we just started ban the sun as this
little nothing way before youtube
and somehow kevin had actually seen our
first little nothing film
and we went to comic con in 2003 and we
have our batman sun t-shirts on trying
to be all cool
and him is batman i walk up because i
was like man that's a that's a great
batman because
because you know as you met him kevin's
he's six five like 240 he's like
obviously he's a life-size batman
and i walk up to him to get this photo
and he he looks down he's like
bat in the sun i know what that is and
it was literally like
how he's like because i'm batman i was
like you're the first person to ever
recognize me
and bat in the sun and it was him and
then we ended up getting to know him so
it's this really serendipitous
wonderful relationship and he's been in
more of a project than anything and he
is
you know the quintessential batman that
everyone loves and stuff
you know so if we ever do another one
i'd love to have you on set just so you
could see
just the impressiveness that he is you
know [ __ ] yeah
in the suit i i saw it years ago at the
comic con but i'd love to see it
uh currently the um the what is what is
what is the ref what does bat and the
sun mean how'd you come up with the name
well he came up with it and uh yeah well
i was watching this thing on bats and
bats come when they fly tonight
they circle around the first couple of
bats come out right at dusk that's why
the symbol is
the sun with the bat flying through the
sun and they're
basically that's the leader yeah they're
basically clearing the area out to make
sure it's safe for
the rest of all the other bats to
eventually come out so
that's i don't like that idea that we're
the bat in the sun the first ones out to
make sure
it's cool and safe yeah so most people
think it's about batman but it's not
it's actually
in my head somebody's kid looked at the
oval
and described the bat symbol as like oh
that's the bat in the sun
because it's like bat with the yellow
all around it
but i like yours it's cool far more
poetic
yeah it's why that dust right when the
sun is just right on the horizon
you get the first couple of bats flying
right through it before it sets
yeah if i was running hbo max i [ __ ]
give you guys a show just because the
father-son anger like the sean keys is
like you can see that
in the press like a lot of sean keys did
an episode this week
like not only do you get the talent on
display as we've seen in the work
but your you guys are adorable
marketable as fun
they make the hero stuff and like you
would just have you know like the
huda names the washouts keys
the russo brothers and stuff but they
would just call you guys the shawn keys
as as a kid growing up like watching
nerd stuff the westmore family
was this big makeup family in hollywood
and so you'd always see like
bud westmore from like the 50s and 60s
and then eventually
you know there's another westmore who
did the star trek next generation stuff
that idea
of this familial legacy through nerd
stuff was always kind of adorable so yes
by all means i'd watch it i get it i get
it right from i'm gonna brag about a
little story about him
like because basically i was going
through his old photo albums and he had
this photo of him dressed up as darth
vader
and i was like what like what was this
and uh and he has it's
back in 77 and you can tell because it's
faded it's got pictures of you know paul
mccartney george harrison behind him so
i was like i gotta post this this is a
cool
this is a cool photo and i posted it and
it went viral
and starwars.com lucasfilm reached out
and they're like what is this from
and i was like from my daddy he's
basically he dressed you know
this before cosplaying was a thing or
they just dressed up
and and i was like this is from like the
premiere of when it came out and they're
like this is
the first person who ever dressed up as
darth vader after
the star wars came out and it was just
star wars then it wasn't new hope
episode four it was just star wars
and i i made my own darth vader outfit
you know went in the garage with a lot
of
plastic and cardboard and duct tape and
spray paint
you know i got the pictures out of a
magazine because it was hard to find a
picture of darth vader then
and uh i made it put it together and uh
you know there was no comic cons then so
i i wore it at a birthday party and then
later that year
with the premiere originally when you
went in theaters yeah
yeah and then for halloween party yeah
and so
i got a few pictures of it and he put it
online i had no idea that
it was gonna and they wrote a whole
article about it saying that he's the
first person ever dressed up as darth
vader which i'm saying
that's like the earliest cosplay of
vader at that point if it's only been
out for a few weeks
and like it's not like everybody came to
episode like to the premiere
no the [ __ ] characters are that's
astounding why'd you do it you just
loved him so much just loved it and uh
you know i i saw it 14 times in the
theater because that's all there was my
dad kept saying you're going to see that
again
like i said yeah because i love it i
love it it was just you know
there was no channels and all the things
we have today and now it's just
everything but back then it's just like
we're going to the movie theater to see
it you know
14 your friends would all get together
and you get the magazines and it was
just a big deal there
it was just you know yeah you can google
it it's on it so just type in first
darth vader cosplayer it's right there
there's pictures up there and everything
that's [ __ ] that's this is nerd
bonafides
the kickstarter that you guys did did
you get fully financed
yeah we did yeah we raised the over half
a million how long did it take
for our new for our new project the
feature we're doing yeah it took it was
two months three for two months
that was good yeah so we got a half a
million dollars for uh
called legend of the white dragon and we
started shooting that in about six weeks
and um um uh that we did dine as easy we
did a kickstarter
or any google for that and that that
i got about 75 000. we did that for a
little shorter um and then we put in
about 50 grand of our own money
to make it you know to make it so it's
perfect yeah just to make it so
do you do you ever get that money back
or that's just no it's just gone but
when it gets back though in sense that
like
the recognition and also you get like a
you're like a big call
you know from like ca signs you and you
you get a different deal so like it's
you're investing in yourself
right so i'm i'm all for for that but
it's just amount of
the attention to detail that we want to
put in the films like you said there's
so much when you when you watch it
you're like that has to cost money and
you're like
it does but we're able to keep the cost
down like the budget was about 127
thousand so um which one and which one
uh 127 was for
uh dying is easy get out of here really
120
yes six they shoot fine looks it yeah
like it's they make the cw shows in
[ __ ] six days
like six seven days for heaven's sakes
you could be make one of these
for god's sakes like it's astounding but
does it
as a creator it sounds like you've got
your own community that keeps you
fulfilled
so much so they they were the ones that
i would imagine got the kickstarter
or fun the movie and whatnot so with
as much as there's a like oh it'd be
great to work for these cats or these
cats
like you're not idly sitting by and
going i hope they'll [ __ ] call
you make your own joy while you make
your own stuff
yeah we're independently kind of sitting
in a sweet spot right now and
we can kind of call our own shots you
know i mean we do we would like to
you know expand and you know work with
the major studio but
at the same time right now things are
manageable
which is really nice and we can uh have
a
better hands control of the creativeness
that what we want to see in there and
just and work faster because of it and
put it in all the attention to detail
and
um because i like said i work with the
hasbro and spawn on like some piranha
stuff and you go through all these
rewrites and it's like i mean
you obviously know what it's like and
it's just this constant like okay we're
shooting soon we have to rewrite this
and do this we have to have like
all these meetings for like well what
color should the yellow be on the helmet
what then you're like oh my gosh
you know so the only person we have to
answer to is each other and what's funny
is the people on set will sometimes if i
don't like it
it'll go to him and if he likes it he's
like aaron come over we should do this
sounds like oh
yeah yeah it's true man like what you
lose
in the unlimited means that you have at
a [ __ ] disney or
warner brothers um you guys have
something that's almost equally as
valuable which is
freedom yeah yeah what you want to tell
the story the way you want to to kind of
just
make everything look the way you want to
and stuff and hearing that you put your
own loot into it as well like as i would
imagine
you didn't you had to do that the first
few times was pay for it when did you
figure out like oh we can start going to
the audience for this
uh that was pretty much like last year
we like we thought like because we
always had i i
really never wanted to ask fans for
money i was like we can do it ourselves
we work in the industry like i said so
we can um
afford it and make those films but then
i was gonna do something bigger and
greater so let's
reach out to the fans we've never really
done that i've never been a big fan of
like oh let's see if you know but
it worked we did two successful
kickstarters and uh it's been really
great and then people also come in and
and donate their time and work because
they're they love
our previous work was able to bring in
like you know doug jones and michael
madsen
you know casper van dien vera bambi all
these like basically people that you
find all over the internet they're like
really excited to jump on
and you know be a part of it because i
know it's going to be something special
you know so like i know our kevin porter
he shot up to like under 200 on imdb
you know like for that two weeks it was
that was just like really
yeah so he was just going all over it so
it's been really
great and it's everyone is such a
community you know with the fans and
with
our cast and group so guys are doing the
lord's work man
it's incredible stuff the most recent
one is dying is easy kids you can check
it out on youtube right
click off from us we'll still be here
and you can go watch uh but uh they're
heading into what is it called
uh legend of the white dragon legend of
the white dragon so you're
you're shooting uh within four weeks you
say six
uh yeah five to six weeks and uh it's
gonna be like a 31 day shoot it's pretty
big so
wow much bigger much bigger than this so
and then they they
they're long days and we go you know we
go super hard on them
um uh like when we we shot with uh
poison ivy like you know she was all
green
uh that actor spirit bama she arrived we
had to get a
hotel right at four o'clock and four in
the morning and then get didn't get
those set until 11
and then we had to shoot that scene you
know so it's like her day was like 20
hours so these people put in so much
time and love to it like everyone there
was just just going hard
you know and that's how we're able to
accomplish what you see on screen you
know so like
everyone is just so passionate you know
about what we're doing with a good
casting crew
yeah and i can't say enough about them
um and actually
our cinematographer's birthday today and
i just wanna wish a happy birthday he's
a huge fan of yours
kevin what's his name his name is eric
aram
eric yeah happy birthday eric
happiest [ __ ] birthday how old is he
how old do you think he is
i think he's uh 36 36 almost 37.
you [ __ ] survived 36 years you clever
son of a [ __ ] it's a dangerous world
out there and you're so
making nerd stuff so happy birthday
making making people happy with the
stuff you make
um it is uh you're doing the lord's work
kids
thank you thank you can i ask you what
just did you have like a favorite moment
in the film or something being a huge
batman fan and a writer because since
the film is so much more
dialogue and psychological driven which
is what i love about your work you know
you don't
you you get right into the mind i'd be
curious what your if you had a favorite
part about dying is easy or something
that just stood out
i'll be honest with you i was shocked to
see madsen show up yeah
that blew my mind where i was like oh
they've got money now
like you know i at that point i waited
to see the end i thought maybe the
warner brothers logo would come up
but you know you've got a master
performer
doing wonderful dialogue like you know
in the midst of
the usual [ __ ] boy this looks good oh
my god that fight looks incredible holy
[ __ ] this looks like
the way these comic book character
characters should look there
there there was a performance in there i
mean there's always performance i don't
want to raise somebody up to lower some
to lower somebody else or something but
like it was
it's crazy like i'm not like sounds
condescending but i was
proud of the fact that i'm like these
cats have come up in the [ __ ] world
man
which indicates one of two things one
you've got all the money which i know
you don't
two you've got all the respect which
clearly you have
people have enjoyed the previous effort
so much that they're like [ __ ] jump
in
and you know for those out there who are
like why is that such a big deal
like you don't understand this business
people don't do [ __ ] unless there's a
[ __ ] check involved once you get paid
to make pretend
you get so [ __ ] lazy and accustomed
to it that like when people ask you to
do something for free or
favor you know it's it's it's people
don't go for that generally speaking
so the fact that they do never has
anything to do with money because none
of us have any money to do this [ __ ]
it has everything to do with the fact
that they like something you did in the
past
something you did [ __ ] touch them so
the fact that you were able to get a
performance like that out of michael
madsen and get michael madsen himself
has everything to
says everything about what you guys have
done previously up till that point
so congratulations thank you very much
appreciate it
again give these [ __ ] kids in hbo max
show for heaven's sakes
and when i say kids i include his father
you never even said anything man
what's your name my name is sean not
confused with my last name
are you serious you're sean sean shanky
sean squared i'm like why didn't you
leave me a m
s-e-a-n like sean connery oh my god the
better spelling not that [ __ ]
s-h-a-w-n thing yeah
um that's tremendous man oh my god sean
shanky that rocks
you have to have a [ __ ] show now
that's like a show name you can see a
credit at the end with the dude typing
and [ __ ] sean shawnke productions
pleasure for uh having you on the show
kids excellent work continue
[ __ ] doing it good luck with white
dragon and [ __ ] 31 days that's a feature
and that's original right it's not
basically yeah
with it when you're done you take it out
into the world it's not going to the
youtube channel right
no no yeah netflix and a small
theatrical release so we're taking it
out yeah
man congratulations um like father like
son
both very creative yeah well thanks for
having on the show big shout out to my
mom who's watching i love you
and uh thanks to all you guys out there
and everybody behind their production
you know
i appreciate it yeah i love what you
guys do i've been a big fan of you guys
and hopefully maybe we can all work
together at some point so keep doing it
dude you guys crossed
man i'll be i'll be an extra in a
heartbeat i don't you know obviously i
don't pull the superhero
figure but i could definitely be
somebody who gets [ __ ] punched in the
face
i'll hold you to that i know fans are
going crazy over it i can take a hit man
watch this [ __ ]
no batman you come up with better
dialogue but
and i probably should have said no
batman before he hit me but we'll work
it out on set but i'm telling you i can
be a guy who gets punched
mark two oh man all right that might be
my reason to do a sequel get you guys in
it
sounds good on board yeah give it up for
the shawn keys everybody
all right thanks guys appreciate it
thank you all right
oh my god how awesome is that doesn't
that just
fill your heart with joy for heaven's
sakes oh father-son
making [ __ ] i don't have a son mark that
interview
made me go like i should have tried
harder i should have had another kid
and maybe had a son um yeah you're doing
all right though
yeah i like my kids she's great but
still how awesome
like you know i had a father and i was a
son
so like i know that relationship and
stuff i'll never know that now
but um you know i'm not like you know
[ __ ] i've got a daughter i love my
daughter but there's some
wonderful dynamic i mean look i make
[ __ ] with my kid too you know what
i am the sean keys i don't know why i'm
[ __ ] going like i wish i was them
i am wondering why i was like dude you
make like nine movies with your kid
you're like i wish i had a kid i could
make [ __ ] with
right so thank god my kid doesn't watch
the show because she'd be like
what do you mean you need to be a sean
key why can't you just be my [ __ ] dad
you know the thing we've been doing like
nine times already yeah
remember how yoga hosers you ruined my
life dad
um yeah man [ __ ] go deep dive on
their [ __ ] if you haven't if you
if that interview didn't [ __ ] make
you want to do it
head over to bat in the sun but i was so
honestly my big
i was so glad i got to ask about the bat
and the sun thing because that for years
i was just like it must mean the symbol
yeah they could get in that other way to
be the symbol and because the bat
was depicted in the sun i was like well
it must be like their way to do the bat
symbol without you know warner brothers
and instead it was just something much
better you know
warrior bounce cleaning the way
all right what is the uh we got
we've already we've talked about uh
wanda vision
we've uh we've interviewed the
documentary soldier
we've uh yeah few weeks my head is still
a few weeks ago
uh falcon of the winter soldier um we've
spoken to the sean keys and whatnot
we did show-and-tell so that means we're
definitely at the news portion of the
show ladies and gentlemen and there is
news to go over man and mark bernardin
he's an old new sound man he knows what
to do with the news
he takes that news and he [ __ ] knows
what to do with it
he breaks that song and he gives it to
you man
where's the trigger where's the trigger
he does he [ __ ] christian bales the
news just for you
he christian fails it all together and
presents it to you ladies and gentlemen
mark bernard with the news
what is the headline what's in the
headlines the the big headline
is a thing that we have talked about for
the last year now
um is that yes black widow
is coming to disney plus after all
um this makes sense it does
it does it does theatrically as well
though right they are they're doing day
and date
same time you know it's it's the disney
premier access so
you can still need to spend 30 bucks to
watch it um
and it won't be until july 9th it was
supposed to be out may 7th they're not
pushing into july 9th
and yeah they're doing both like if you
can go to seed in theater go see the
theater if you want to stay home
stay home if you want to do both you can
do both
um and i think it's really smart because
this way
they get to make all of the money that's
on the table as opposed to leaving any
of it aside
you know by july 9th like more theaters
may be open more people will be
vaccinated more people might feel
comfortable
going to the theater and if you don't
they get your money anyway
like it was probably going to be it's
not the best of all possible worlds the
best of all possible worlds is there was
no pandemic
and you can still pack a movie theater
and open it worldwide at the same time
but
absent you know a tesseract to go back
in time and
and change things very on brand very own
brand
very own brand this is this is the best
version of that
um so yeah you know according to
to disney's uh let's see kareem daniel
disney
media and entertainment distribution
chairman i met with him i met with him
on um
howard the duck i think yeah that's a
real guy
i feel like it was so weird i was like i
know he's famous hold on
um but today's announcement reflects our
focus on providing customer choice
and serving the evolving preferences of
audiences by leveraging a flexible
distribution strategy in a dynamic
marketplace that is beginning to recover
from a global pandemic
we will continue to employ the best
options to deliver the walt disney
company's
unparalleled storytelling to fans and
families around the world um
and i think what this also signifies is
that
they've waited as long as they can to
get the marble train rolling again
you know like i'm sure they would have
rather waited until august or november
or december
but they have an entire storytelling
machine
that is built upon these interlocking
pieces to them and so swapping wan
division
and and [ __ ] winter soldier wasn't
you know
the hardest thing for them to do not
exactly what they wanted at all but
they got that done but as characters
begin to appear like i think you know
florence pugh
from from black widow appears in in
falcon winter soldier at some point or
maybe she appears in hawkeye but you
can't have that
until you have the the black widow movie
coming out all of the
and the other stack of trains in this
particular rail yard
need to start moving out and i think
that they waited they held a year
on on black widow but i don't think they
can hold any more
um so i think that yeah we talked about
it
months and months and months ago that
this was probably going to be
the uh the result of this and so
we got it we got confirmation july 9th
black widow
long story short good for us
we're gonna get to see this [ __ ] at home
if you're too scared to go out
by then i will have had my vaccination
so perhaps i will find this
uh movie to be mask worthy and
yes you know or i i have started taking
to renting out a movie theater like you
can you can 100 do that amc for like
are they still gonna do that though once
they open up for business and [ __ ] like
that
um i think so long as they're throttled
at 25
capacity um i still think they'll rent
out theaters
you know because honestly there's always
a small house that's
they don't have a ton of movies in
theaters to to fill a giant multiplex
with
so even if you have black widow on one
screen and raya and nobody on another
screen
your average multiplex has another 20
screens that are lying dormant
i'm totally doing that i'm renting a
theater to go see [ __ ]
black widow i'm doing it to go see
godzilla and kong
next next weekend [ __ ] yes
i got a big tv though i got 103 inch tv
so i can rock that one in my bedroom
like look i have nothing but respect for
khan godzilla but
you know i can do that one at home and
probably enjoy it a lot more than if i
went to the theater but
black widow you know marvel's never got
let me down by going to a movie theater
so indeed definitely go out for that
um so yes we're getting that which it
also kind of trickles down in the
release
plan like shang chi um and the legend
the ten rings
now open september 3rd and slides back
from its previous july 9th
date um some other stuff like free guy
the mat
the ryan reynolds movie is going to
august 13th the king's man moves back
four months to december 22nd
uh kenneth branagh's death on the nile
moves back
man never came out no
oh my god you're right yeah everything's
harder to hold that
it was supposed to be um was that a
valentine's day movie that was a
february movie and they just held it
yeah
wow they expect it to be that big i
would imagine that would have been one
of those titles they're like yeah put it
on
put it on a streamer i don't know i mean
the the kingsmen movies have all done
pretty well especially you know overseas
internationally and so
like you know while everybody's staying
at home
did matthew vaughn direct this one
yeah um
yeah look uh you know i'm interested of
course i like the kingsman movies but
like you know you'll watch that one at
home
marvel is a duck man's loving life my
friend
i don't like to i used to do this
because like zen but like isn't that
what's the i don't want it to be like
isn't there a racist [ __ ] thing
there is there the the white power okay
so that is
so when if i do this if i'm doing zen
that could be misread as somebody being
like you white power [ __ ]
um i don't know both not an upside down
one it's not like uh mark
mark what are the white power symbols
well
your extensive racist research that he
uncovered the litany of white powers
you know when you flash them when you're
out in public and [ __ ]
what are your white power signs
i mean there's there's the wu-tang but
that's not a white power side
and then there's the wakanda forever i
got to learn to stop
doing that though at a certain point
things being okay became racist so
i gotta what about this like that ain't
nothing is it i don't
think so like i always throw up the
horns
and you know i'm sure that offends some
people who are like that's satanic but
come on grow up
yeah just you know throw out the thwhips
throughout this the spider thwips
that's true you know that's good i could
do that
[ __ ] i'm shooting webb
can't you see i'm shooting webs i'm
going to [ __ ] that's going to be my
new jeff's kiss
i'm shooting webs i love that idea so
much i'm shooting wet
i'm ejaculating webs all over the place
um all right what else we got um
let's see according to warner media ceo
ann sarnoff the snyder versus dead
um why they had it was a huge hit for
him wasn't it their second most watched
thing or one of the most watched things
ever
i mean it was um they they haven't
released any watching
or any um audience metrics yet
um but she was asked a question you know
the campaign for the release the snyder
cut has moved into a new phase it's now
restore the snyder verse that's right it
was uh trending for a while the other
day the same day
uh i think they put out like the suicide
squad poster or something like that
right was the day the restore the snyder
verse uh was trending so
yeah i mean i'm all for it man
especially if it's like on hbo max like
[ __ ] do it all
do the do the uh long cut of suicide
squad let david air go back
in and [ __ ] throw zach snyder a bunch
of money every other year to make a
goddamn thing man like why not
unless they know something i don't her
uh her response was
i appreciate that they love zach's work
and we are very thankful for his many
contributions to dc
we're just so happy that he could bring
his kind of justice league to life
because that wasn't in the plan until
about a year ago with that comes the
completion of his trilogy we're very
happy we've done this
but we're very excited about the plans
we have for all the multi-dimensional dc
characters that are being developed
right now
the follow-up question was will there be
more of these director's cuts will we
see david ayer's cut of suicide squad
and her answer is
we won't be developing david ayer's cut
period
why it's all there um i think
they are probably way more focused on
james gunn's
cut of the suicide squad than david
ayer's cut and so
creating marketplace confusion um so
so close to two different things fair
enough fair enough but it doesn't mean
they should rule it out they should just
be like we're gonna wait a year
two years or something like that yeah
who knows
you know the the the revolving door of
executives in hollywood
um seems to make old things possible in
ways that they never have been before
not to say that she's getting fired but
just saying that
there may be a new dude who comes in
five years it's like you know what
do we still have that let's do that um
so but your take on it she was like it's
done
kids you got as much snyder as we're
giving you
now [ __ ] off you say that but
it was like what more do you want from
us we've given you what you asked for
i know but like you know if you give a
mouse a cookie mark i don't know if you
ever read that book
indeed children's classic it leads to
all sorts of things
so maybe the answer to that is um don't
give a mouse a cookie
too late too late we've all eaten the
cookie now we want
now we want a glass of milk or whatever
the [ __ ] was next yeah and if you give
him a glass of milk he's going to want a
doughnut and if you give him a doughnut
he's going to want a cheeseburger
cheeseburger is going to want global
domination so do not give that mouse a
cookie
and sarnoff read those books before she
gave that interview because she was like
oh no
i'm not giving these mice cookies
anymore no more badger cookie
books closed here's a mouse trap [ __ ]
off
um i guess they got a lot of new stuff
to make you know they've made a lot of
announcements about things that are
coming
and um you know they certainly
are to be commended for [ __ ] doing
the snyder cut
like she said in the statement a year
ago that [ __ ] was never going to happen
and now it exists but uh
you know i i i mean look you got all the
money in the world all i'm saying is
like
why not just make everyone happy and be
like look every once in a while he's
going to come back and do a thing for us
because
he loves these characters so we yeah we
will keep the snyder verse going
especially out of respect now who said
this this was ann sarno from warner
brothers
from warner media yes warner media yeah
there seems to be a very clear
delineation between the warner media
folks and the hbo max folks
the hbo max folks the way i understand
it like [ __ ]
love zach because like
this was the the shiny jewel in the
crown
zack snyder's justice league that got
hbo max a lot of attention and stuff
for a whole [ __ ] year almost so
but uh it wasn't somebody from hbo max
making the statement huh
no because ultimately they report up to
her
um you know and it's and there is no
figures we have no idea what the ratings
were like we have no idea most
importantly
for warner media and hbo max is what the
effect on subscriptions
um was because of the snyder cut because
that's the only metric they care about
at this point is
how many people signed up for the
service because we had this available to
them
and and more importantly will they stick
around will we retain them or are they
going to drop the service
right here here you go kids if you're
like i want to restore the snyder verse
this is the only way to do it don't drop
your hbo max subscription
like make sure nobody drops their hbo
max subscription
so that hbo understands that you were
there for that
and maybe you'll get more that's how you
got it in the first place
expectation that you would show up and
then you showed up
so now you know it's possible
to extend the life of this i mean right
now based on this interview
sounds like they're shutting the door
but
again not giving up hope is what gave
the
zack snyder's justice league aka the
snyder cut life at all
so vom these people like i'm i'm still
i'm still dug in i'm still like yeah
yeah restore the snyder verse
because it worked once again if you give
a mouse or cookie
stop picking fights just tell them you
love it [ __ ] movie
just just just lie to me would you just
lie
mark i mean kids mark got he got beat up
like you know and everyone we get
reduced to two categories on this show
he cries and loves everything he [ __ ]
hates everything that's not marble
neither of those things are true i do
cry a lot
and i do tend to i only talk about the
things that i like so that's why it
seems like i
like everything but i have it on good
authority
that mark loves dc stuff
for example the suicide squad trailer
dropped this week
and marcus nothing but great things to
say about it take them
take the stage mark and tell them how
much you love this uh you know the
the thing that i love about it you know
i'm gonna let you speak well i'm gonna
let you finish as kanye said
i'm gonna go refill my glass while
you're while you're talking oh sounds
good
um i mean the thing that i love about it
is
you know it's it's a tonal shift you
know it's it's the reason why
i i liked the the first suicide squad
trailer
like it feels fun it feels like it's
it's
it it's promising a good time and
i think that regardless of how you feel
about zack snyder's movies
um regardless of the love you might have
for them regardless of the
the sort of malaise you might have
towards them um
they're not a good time that is not the
story he's setting out to tell
and that's fine not every story needs to
be a good time um and not every
filmmaker needs to be operating in that
in that mode but watching james gunn
suicide squad trailer
left me feeling like this was a movie
that a
um is going to be interesting to watch
it's going to be fun to watch it's going
to be
um i mean it's way brighter than
anything else that i've seen come out of
dc in a while
um but also the feeling that i'm going
to get the movie they're
promising me in the trailer which i
think was not the case with david a her
suicide squad
um that trailer and that sort of that
that distillation of that story was not
made by j
was not made by david ayer i mean
there's the the long story of how
the film was sort of recut by the guys
who got the trailer and they kind of
iced them out of the process and then
they recut the movie to make it more
like the tone on the trailer
but that's not what the movie was under
underneath it all and so it all kind of
got
you know just watered down and is
nobody's
best version of what that film is but i
have a hundred percent feeling
that this is james gunn through and
through that he
set out to to do his like weird ass
dirty dozen
meets magnificent seven meets you know
guardians to be fair like he's bringing
a lot of that tone to it
and i'm here for it you know i'm here
for stallone as king shark
you know i'm here for kaiju
and what's up with your mic your mic
sounds like you're breaking up
am i yeah i don't know nothing's changed
maybe it's just me maybe well jc killed
the third screen that the
sean keys were on jc did something go
wrong with my sound
bam pure ass in here jc uh you sound
okay on my end
yeah maybe it's just me you might have
mark it looked like you had a bit of an
internet
hiccup so it could have been there
i can hear kevin i can hear you but you
both sound really staticky
oh it's probably your bluetooth headset
there
yeah yeah loud and clear for us i fixed
it
never mind um yes
uh stallone and back to you
i mean you know like and ultimately it's
kind of what i want
from a superhero movie i i i don't need
it to always be light and ephemeral and
bouncy good time happy
but i need you know the thing that i'm
always hoping for from the dc movies
that i rarely get
and you know you got it from shazam and
i appreciated that but there's some
total variety
is that you know some of these are going
to feel you know
lighter and funner and have a different
you know sort of
way that we're going to to achieve this
storytelling desire
something can 100 percent be a little
bit serious and a little bit modeling
like i love the nolan movies
you know and and nobody will ever say
that christopher nolan does not take
himself seriously and i'm okay with that
but i feel like that's the only mode
these movies have been
for almost you know 10 years with the
exception of wonder woman which i loved
you know with the exception of aquaman
which like hey it doesn't make any sense
but it's at least not that it's going
for something it's energetic it is maybe
even too energetic at times
it doesn't matter um but give me that
variety
variety is the slice of life as they say
and so feeling this level of sort of
manic joy
out of a dc movie is a welcome
welcome turn for me kevin how did you
feel
uh-oh
i'm gonna say the thing you failed to
say you were very eloquent but
all you need to say is one [ __ ] word
starro
i've been wanting to say that for a long
time i knew it was gonna be starro as
the bad guy i think i talked about on
this show i was like i know who the bad
guy is and [ __ ] and i kept it quiet
that whole [ __ ] time man but like the
moment i heard that [ __ ]
i was like i want to marry james gunn i
want to fire that gun into my mouth
like you know he picked starro
it's not like you know kevin foggy was
like here's the story and it's sorrow
so you know he [ __ ] picked starro and
starro is one of the most
visually interesting uh dc
villains and you've never really seen it
in live action man we're gonna see
[ __ ] people
with starfishes over their faces
and as we saw on the trailer where he's
like guide you
we're gonna see [ __ ] starro himself
like that's so good that is
fan service of the highest
[ __ ] degree and it just proves that
gunn
can fire in both directions like you
know he [ __ ] obviously he's great at
marvel
and based on what i've seen from this
trailer alone
he's crushing it with dc you know and
even if you don't know who starro is
the function it serves is there's a
giant [ __ ] starfish that's a big bad
guy
which feels like it fits in this movie
which is uh ultimately like a comedy
and so if my mom goes to see this like
yeah giant [ __ ] starfish
makes sense that's ludicrous i'd like to
see where this goes
you know and i'm here for it and if you
know who it is it's they made a [ __ ]
starro movie
this is amazing amazing
um do you give james gunn the
challenge of the super friends movie
next
to bring it back next last week oh god
yes
or somebody in chat uh yes i have chat
open if you're gonna criticize me
leave me alone um someone in chat said
give james gunn the
uh justice league of america or justice
league international
and kevin mcguire you know [ __ ] uh
uh jm de matas run of the book and i was
like what a great [ __ ] idea but
this is better than that because this is
r-rated action
blood guts people gonna be cursing and
[ __ ] like that
me and the snit on uh chat says bathos
or bathos you want bathos this is
screwing up the mcu get real man
i don't know if that person meant to say
pathos i think so
um but that's not though bathos could be
a demon that we don't know about
yeah or maybe like less bats we don't
want to be relaxing in a nice hot tub
that's true or maybe it's just like you
got to take your bathtubs
like tummy time like with [ __ ]
cereal that i don't know about louis
johnson says or louis johnson says give
kevin smith the next suicide squad movie
don't i saw the trailer for that movie i
would never have given you
anything like that
you want that guy doing what he does
best
give those cats i'm the guy you want
talking about those movies
he's the guy you want making those
movies um
let me tell you something if they were
like you have suicide squad you could do
whatever you want
never in a million years would i think
to do [ __ ] sorrow
but that's when i heard that [ __ ] i was
like oh my god
like this guy is [ __ ] crazy talented
and the
trailer proves that out cannot [ __ ]
wait
to see yes and can i i might be someone
i go to the theater to see
even though i can watch it on hbo man
yep or again you can do both like
i'll 100 watch godzilla versus kong way
more times than i would go see in the
movie theater but i'll still go see in
the movie theater
buick space wagon tells us bathos is an
anti-climactic lapse in tone
eric synchronous says bathos is what you
magically
channel in order to win the bath awards
um daniel friedman said oh uh
bathos is an anti-climax caused by a
shift in tone
was this something had you never heard
of this expression before i've never
heard of it
i've only ever used the word pathos um
wow which i don't even think we said
today have you ever heard of the
expression
milkshake duck um
i've heard of it but i don't know what
the context is for it that's what
happens when
the internet falls in love with a person
like the guy
who had the red sweater in the [ __ ]
one debate red sweater guy or whatever
[ __ ] everyone like he's so cute
and then like they found posts of his
where he was like
talking about wanting to see naked
vagina or something like that
well it was a little scandalous and [ __ ]
so milkshake
duck is when the internet falls in love
with somebody and then finds out some
[ __ ] about that person within a few days
and then
turns on the [ __ ] dude so the
cinnamon toast crunch shrimp dude
who we know i don't know if you know him
but i know jensen i don't
yeah i mean jensen has gallery 1988 out
here
in los angeles that did the crazy cult
shows um he did
uh pass the mic which me and jay
were on uh years ago when like uh
years and years ago jay did like i think
lines of dialogue and one of his hot
carl songs and stuff
um we had one of his podcasts get up on
this was on smodcast.com for a long time
so i've known
like jensen for years and stuff and i
remember when that you know when he
started tweeting about the cinnamon
toast crunch it was blowing up i was
like good for him man
like [ __ ] look at this it's gone
viral and then it
somehow came back to bite him in the ass
and that's where i learned the
expression milkshake duck which i'd
never heard before but on the internet
they're like
that's a total milkshake duck and i was
like i i wasn't aware of this which made
me feel really old mark
you got to remember i was the guy that
introduced people to the term snowball
and snowballing you know and so i felt
hip
i felt like i got my finger on the pulse
but now i'm like oh i'm
a little old man i'm like whoa what's a
milkshake duck
get off my lawn or tell me what it is
i'm so terrified
um yeah yeah we saw that happen this
week but that's not really comic book
news anyway
anyway here for suicide squad uh
cannot wait and shan't have to wait for
too long because it's coming out in a
matter of months
which august right yeah so lovely
birthday gift for me cell tv said
invincible talk please
i have not yet watched invincible mark
has seen some invincible
uh you can take that one yeah and i saw
the first two episodes i haven't seen
the third one yet
but you know as i told kirkman when he
was here like i kind of love it you know
i love
how both earnest it is and how it treats
um you know your your protagonist mark
grayson i love how
extreme it gets especially at the end of
the first episode which is
a gnarly [ __ ] turn if you don't know
this story
um you know but ultimately i just i i
love that the attention to care
that it has for for both this character
for the world it's building for
superheroes in general
you know there there is something to be
said for having a creator adapt his own
work
and then being given the challenge of
expanding it and broadening it and
deepening it
you know and especially if that dude is
as talented as kirkman is you know as he
said on the shows like i wrote
many of these stories you know 15 20
years ago
and sort of come back in and like look
at those original books and say oh
i thought this was just gonna be a
one-to-one translation i've got to
rewrite these things and in the
rewriting
you know he went deeper and and so far
i think it's a really great adaptation
of work because it has nothing but
fidelity to the original source material
to the point where he got corey walker
to redesign all of the the animation
models for the characters
um but also it's it's it's really
emotional and moving
and it's a father-son story but what
happens if your dad is this dead and
it's a mother-son story where
and it's a true story and it's a teenage
coming-of-age story and it's all these
things and so
yeah no i'm here for it i'm on board
you're selling me i'm gonna watch i
watched uh
instead this uh weekend i i binged
didn't take me very long cause there's
only eight episodes uh
season two of solar opposites which i
absolutely adore
justin roiland and what's mike i forget
the other guy's name escapes
um but uh i loved season one and uh
season two they dropped i guess on
friday or something like that and
oh my god it's just so [ __ ] wonderful
i laughed out loud many times
and um they they do this thing did you
ever watch season one
i did not despite the number of times
you told me to they do this thing where
you know they do their alien story but
in the background one of the aliens
shrinks people and puts them in like
like a habitrail like an arm human wall
and so periodically they just go and
tell
wall stories like they start on the
aliens and then they just go into the
wall and the show becomes about
like these like it becomes an action
movie like a compelling dramatic action
movie it's [ __ ] crazy
but you know eight episodes went so by
so [ __ ] fast
but insanely funny [ __ ] great vocal
talent
like love it absolutely loved it so
now i will when i'm alone in the morning
and [ __ ] i'm like what should i watch
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go down on invincible this
time based on your review
um alan g says i watched the last
blockbuster on netflix last blockbusters
this wonderful documentary
about the last blockbuster uh that's
very nostalgic for
not just blockbusters but video stores
in general
and uh because the artwork that they
chose
features uh me pretty prominently on the
on the
on netflix a lot of people assume that i
made it so i've been getting a lot of
twitter congratulations like i love the
last blockbuster and i'm like me too
i was just one of the cats that was in
it as well i wish i'd made it
because it's really great but no i
didn't make it but in any event
alan g says i watched the last
blockbuster on netflix
the closed caption ids kevin as
jason is that a joke or a screw-up
it's certainly not a joke i would
imagine it's a
screw-up but i've i've been around 27
years so i'm comfortable
that anybody watching it you know is
going to be like well
that's incorrect if they don't no i mean
honestly we are interchangeable to some
degree
a lot of people call him silent j and
bob and silent j and [ __ ] so
you know i can't really complain that i
was misidentified as jason it's an honor
god damn it
i wish i was jason muse so we we shot
your
they shot your interview at scum and
villainy which it was
i was geeking out over seeing scum and
villainy as like the featured
photo on netflix but i'm thanked in the
credits twice
it's like special thanks i'm like the
third person and then the last person
so i've gotten a ton of messages saying
wow jc was so involved in this they
thanked him twice
so i think that they're uh
i think that their proofreader may have
uh taken a day off because i don't think
i should have been
thanked twice i wouldn't think twice
gave him a hell of a location for the
interview and stuff
uh my wife was telling me she was we had
a fight
one day like last week nothing major but
like [ __ ] like
argument screw you [ __ ] leave the
room and [ __ ]
she was like i was so [ __ ] mad at you
i just opened my computer just put on
something to watch
and then your stupid [ __ ] face showed
up
telling me about the last blockbuster
she's like i can't [ __ ] escape you
like that's right nobody could escape
kevin smith
um all right what else we got um
speaking of dc
i think we were speaking of dc a couple
of castings um which
seems super [ __ ] cool um black adam
at least according to dwayne johnson
said star of black adam is welcoming
pierce brosnan to the cast as dr
fate i mean look the fact that it's
piers brosnan is nice but you had me at
dr
fate man they're doing the kent nelson
doctor fate like you know
now of course marvel has established
doctor strange
uh so we've seen a sorcerer supreme of
sorts
um you know for those that don't follow
this stuff closely dr fate
is dc's doctor strange uh master of
mystic arts so to speak and whatnot
he wears uh the helmet of naboo
um and then is filled with that spirit
to become
dr fate uh i've always loved this
character he's got a great [ __ ] look
the helmet is amazing hopefully they
keep the color pattern
color scheme you know of his outfit and
stuff but getting
[ __ ] pierced brosnan is a great
choice yeah like
not like it's nice gives him an age too
because that character you can go any
number of directions with it wasn't
always kent nelson
at one point it was kent and instead
nelson there was a man and a woman
who made him under faith yeah i think
that was the demattus front jm to
madison
but um i can't wait to see this
character in a movie
and black adam is not a character that
i'm like super
like into and stuff but you know i'm
there
i'm there like he has said something on
twitter
um fairly recently just tonight uh
dwayne the rock johnson where he was
talking about i got an announcement
about black adam and i'm wondering if
it's happening or if it happened yet
you know what i should just ask i'm
looking on my phone but
chat hey chat wake up
did uh [ __ ] did
the rock say anything yet
get back to us on that yeah i'm looking
on the
it don't look like it hasn't announced
it yet
aquaman two is trending why did they
announce that [ __ ]
i don't know here's the current schedule
for upcoming dc movies
the suicide squad is august 6th the
batman
is march 4th 2022 black adam
is july 29th 2022
the flash is november 4th 2022
aquaman 2 is december 16th
2022 so right now in 2022
you're getting the batman in march
black adam in july the flash in november
and aquaman 2 in december and then
shazam fury of the gods is june
2nd 2023. wow
yeah apparently uh he took over the rock
took over a billboard in times square to
announce
the july 29 2022 date that's the new
information is the date
yeah got it yeah um so yeah we get
pierce bros and his doctor fate
and helen mirren has been cast and
shazam fury the gods
as the villain wells they'll say who i
thought
mr mind no she's playing um hespera
um who is a new character with no
apparent
dc comics counterpart
so making up some new [ __ ] why
i don't know you got a [ __ ] toy chest
full of [ __ ] ip why are you making up
a character
that's so 90s why would you make up a
character
um the only the only reason i could see
that version
is to be able to surprise people
like if you know too much about it then
you know too much about it
um so like there's something to be said
for the off-speed pitch that nobody sees
coming which is helen mirren
who has no trajectory that any fans are
aware of
i mean just imagining that they're lying
to us that she's playing some character
we've never heard of who could she
possibly be
playing in the dc universe um
i mean there's there's a version of her
as
as as granny goodness
i mean yeah but i guess that's not going
to happen katsuka 1992 said she's the
daughter of atlas
uh jay scott for real in chat says this
is probably a red heading for
a red herring for a reveal i know but
who reveal of who
like who could it possibly be i mean the
only reason why i would say granny
muscle coach said helen mirren is
on is that
allegedly you know david duvane is still
making a new gods movie
um so fabian santos said
helen mirren is mephisto
[Laughter]
torres 88 says she could be controlled
by mr mine i like that thinking
i like that thinking tories it allows me
to keep thinking that mr mind is going
to be the big bad in this movie because
that's what they promised at the end of
the last movie
i want him to fight a worm mark i'll
give the man what he wants
not what is he a caterpillar
he's not a worm he's a caterpillar right
oh i don't know man mr mind you're like
i don't i don't go deep on mr mine
um terry mcginnis says she could be
morgan le faye
you know but why not just say that that
wouldn't be like a big reveal
like morgan le faye and as big as like
catwoman or some [ __ ]
now if she was catwoman oh yes please
yes
selena kyle cat woman of a certain age
cat cougar um
walrus walrus onion says a worm with
glasses you're absolutely [ __ ] right
that's what i want
geez um all right what else we got um
hold on adam wall says helen mirror does
victor garber
still couldn't get that everywhere
either because she'd be so good at
playing victor garber
that she would [ __ ] boycott me as
well
listen i would do this except i'm victor
garber now and he would never do this
yes um at a wondercon at home panel this
weekend there is a there's a panel for
hulu's uh
marvel's modoc series
and revealed a couple of voice actors
who are coming to
coming to play namely john hamm
will be doing the voice of iron man
nathan fillion will be finally
playing wonder man and says oh [ __ ] real
quick
for years and years and years um whoopi
goldberg is playing pound cakes
and bill hader as angar the screamer
and the leader any spy in the leader as
well
yes that's very cool that was one of the
series the cartoons
the animations that was uh involved in
that hulu thing
that uh we were gonna do for a minute
with howard the duck
um but they're still doing theirs
obviously they were
farther down the line in production and
so marvel said yeah finish
right um there's another one coming too
um hit monkey
i think right yeah squirrel girl got uh
got kibasha that was never one of ours
though it was uh
those two and then uh howard the duck
and uh um
and tigra i think it was right
that was the first one to hit the
chopping block
and then all of a sudden one day we got
the call and was like
all right but we had never shot anything
we'd never
it was just we were in scripting phase
whereas the modoc
animation was like further way further
down the road like i remember they
showed me a clip of that and i was like
holy [ __ ]
look so [ __ ] cool well that's good
cass jon ham is iron man i'm here
iron ham [ __ ] yeah yes ham it up am it
up
uh hawkeye is getting a spin-off series
um
yeah when's that start i mean hawkeye
hawkeye is later this year i don't know
i think it's like october november i'm
not sure if they've given an official
date yet
um but yeah centering around the
character
echo um who is a deaf native american
superhero
who has the talent to imitate any
opponent's fighting style created by
david mack and
uh david mackay or jocas david mac and
joe casada
um so yeah she's spinning out of that um
blah blah blah and i think yeah
like hawkeye is where we will see um
florence pugh
reprising her black widow role as elena
bellova
in what uh hawkeye yeah yeah so they
better show us that movie
right and they better show us that movie
yeah i think that's that's as we said
before the reason why they're dropping
black widow when they are so listen we
have to
this is part of a very carefully
constructed chronology that we got to
put out there we get to see the task
master in action
yes yes
we talked a couple weeks ago about a
zatanna movie
that we we heard was coming from bad
robot and warner brothers
um
and so now we have a writer for said
zatanna movie
kevin smith no
i'm sorry um it is the uh filmmaker
emerald fennel who is currently asking
who can speak to the female magician
experience more than me
um fennel is a great choice man she uh
of course did uh
the promising young woman she played in
if you watch the crown she's the one who
plays camilla parker bowles
but uh she also worked on killing eve
right like seasons one and two
so this this was a smart choice i saw
this earlier in the week and i was like
that's good that's real good
yeah i mean it's it's the the picture of
promising young women is nominated for
five oscars
of which ms fennell is up for three of
those
as producer best picture director and
original screenplay category so
yeah like let's give this this fine
young woman this promising young woman
um a dc movie i'm here for it
lisa cagle is asking on chat motu
marketing question can we get a fighter
style game but using mo two characters
maybe with pax using thundercats gi joe
transformers
what about a racing game using motu
characters lisa these are all fantastic
ideas but i
they don't come to me for that like
what toys and games should we make
they're mattel they've been doing this
since
i was in my father's balls so they've
got a plan um
just like the cylons they've got a plan
um but uh those are great suggestions
and i'll pass them on to the folks i
know of mattel and stuff
but uh yeah i'm not in charge of that i
wish i was
it's funny what people think you're in
charge of you know when you're
working on a he-man show and stuff and
they're like well can you make sure the
[ __ ] toys look like this i'm like
no and not because i'm obstinate just
because like
i was as much [ __ ] influence in power
as you do like they're
they've been doing [ __ ] they've been
making toys for years without me they'll
make toys for years after me
they don't need my input and stuff but
it that does sound cool racing game
would be cool but more importantly a
fighting game
i think that'd be badass i mean she got
a little crazy with the hey man throwing
the thundercats and robocop or whatever
the [ __ ] but like
you know matt motu's got enough ip on
their own but
they they would be a great [ __ ] video
game for sure it's
i'm sure it's coming sure it's on the
roof you could do the thing where like
prince adam or he-man is a character in
like mortal kombat or whatever and so
his finishing blow is i have the power
and then [ __ ] lightning bolts and
hearts explode
now i want to play this video game that
doesn't exist
um what other news we got the last news
story we have
is about comic-con is about you know we
we realized back in january february
that there would be no comic-con in july
but there was word that there would be
some kind of event happening in november
and so over the weekend
slash friday thursday whenever the hell
it was
comic-con released a statement saying
that there would be a three-day special
edition of the event
a thanksgiving weekend um the hope being
of course by thanksgiving weekend colby
conditions will allow for large-scale
public gatherings
of this kind um i'm of two minds here
yes sir number one yay comic-con
number two thanksgiving weekend
like tell them why thanksgiving
people are bumping into thanksgiving
mark i mean i think that
the the biggest issue that like i
personally have and i think a decent
chunk of the internet has
is if if by thanksgiving there's a world
in which
i can travel anywhere um
it is not going to be the comic-con much
as that would be fun
but rather to see the family that i
haven't seen in
a year and a half and so i i have a
feeling that there will be
lots of decisions being made at that
time to finally leave
you know the cocoon and go see people um
you know i'm pretty i'm not gonna say
i'm pretty sure but i think that the
the the dividing line is do i go see my
nerds or do i go see my family
um and so who who knows how they will
fall
but to to force a choice upon people
like this
at a time when you know and who knows
how many people are going to be able to
get tickets for this
you know it it i can't imagine it being
the you know 149 000 people inside that
convention hall
plus another 200 000 people out in the
gaslamp district
i i'm not down for that many people and
they can't make that they'll let that
happen i'm not saying they can't let
that i i just doubt
it's going to be comic-con as we know it
you know they're going to
even if for a bunch of us are [ __ ]
vaccinated they're still going to bring
those numbers down
like yeah you know it's not clear at all
you know
the badge cost or attendance capacity
and all that stuff
is is still details that are being
worked out so i have to think to your
point that it becomes a smaller affair
the same way that disneyland
is like if you want to open up great
we're at 25 capacity 35
capacity california residents only we're
not welcoming people in from from out of
state let alone international
you know there are ways to kind of
throttle the attendance for an event
like this
but you know and hey there are people
who absolutely you know
hate their families or don't have family
to speak up and for whom
this community is their family and would
happily spend it with
spending thanksgiving with folks in san
diego and to them i say godspeed
go have a blast um i don't know if i'm
ready there yet
you read my mind can you also i was just
going to text you um they're dropping
off veggie grill
it's coming my my
familiar oh hello jen the our
our our uh our um
teammate
we did a thing yesterday
uh we went and played family feud we
can't tell you the results
because the show doesn't air for a few
months apparently but
me and mark and jay
and jen and ralph were a team
called the smod squad and we played uh
my my i don't know if i could did he put
his up on social media
uh i'm not sure but you know if if in
any of our pictures we happened to catch
them
um and they encouraged us to share these
things on social media so
i mean up here without sp i won't spoil
it but we played somebody
who i know and have worked with in the
past they were the other team
and he put together a team of his own so
um
you know after watching the show for
years and years we were actually there
with steve harvey and playing family
feud and we got to do [ __ ] like
you know the opening of the the show
when i was a kid was the family's frozen
behind like a [ __ ] wall
and then look like a photo and then they
say their names and then they come to
life and they go to the phone
they still do that [ __ ] and they call
that the americana part they're like
well for the americana part of the show
i was like what's that and they're like
well that's like moments like where you
guys are frozen
or huddling for getting ready to steal
they call that the americana part of the
show because it's
such a big part of the show from the
beginning or whatever
um but yes you'll tune in and find out
how we didn't ship but how
uh what was it like was that your first
game show it was my first game show
and and it of the things that you have
called me and asked if i wanted to do
this is the weirdest of them yeah i was
like hey man
do you want to go on family feuds like
whoever did i think that would be a
question you'd ask me
but sure man let's go on family view
and let's stare into the the velvet
abyss
of steve harvey's none more black
mustache
like it's it's mesmerizing it really is
like unsettling almost it is a sea
of of facial hair [ __ ]
million dollar mustache he might have it
insured oh he's got it lloyd's of london
like raquel welch's legs and uh and and
steve harvey's mustache
but yeah it was it was crazy weird and
totally surreal
and even in with all the coved protocols
and all that stuff it was still
bonkers in the best way
um the nostalgic pod blast said the
audience warmup guy is awesome in family
feud
harvey was fun yeah the audience warm-up
guy like
is the audience warm-up guy at comic-con
as well oh yeah
yeah so when i talked to him yesterday
he said you don't recognize me because
i'm wearing the mask but he's like i
open for you all the time i always see
you at comic-con
but he was good well what i was really
impressed by too was
um
steve harvey was so like between acts
you know when like hey we're gonna go to
break
you know they they do break when we're
shooting the show and then they set up
and do other things and talk about the
next act and
blah blah and every game show i've been
on that's when they grab the host and
they go through like all right we're
doing this now we're doing this we're
doing this
and steve instead like worked the
audience and the audience was limited
because it was you know [ __ ] covered
right but he walked right to the edge of
the stage and gave a [ __ ]
one-man show for like 10 minutes for
that
story time with steve harvey it was i
mean you know true comedian at heart
where he's just like
there's an audience [ __ ] i'm gonna go
make him laugh and [ __ ]
it was nice to see yeah and i wouldn't
even call it like work ethic like what a
good work ethic like you could tell
he likes to [ __ ] go engage in
storytelling you know
it's in the it's in the blood man it's
like yeah
and it's like and once you've been doing
that show for as long as he's been doing
it
the rhythms are such that like you don't
have to really tell them what's
happening like you don't have to give
them much guidance in between
in between those breaks it was like
listen i know we're going to do you're
going to tell me what we're going to do
i'm going to talk to these people for a
while
and then we're going to come back from
break and we'll do the rest of the show
um it was fun though it was absolutely
fun yeah all right but wait back to the
original point
comic con yes um um this
is a terrible idea mark where can i get
tickets
let's be honest this is something that a
lot of us will [ __ ] about
but probably wind up doing anyway i mean
you know for me
san diego's not that far of a trip uh i
don't need turkey
so you know vegan thanksgiving is is
just a thursday
um and i think my family has been
so cooped up for so long that if i was
like we're going to comic con they'd be
like all right let's get in the car
so i might actually still be engaging
with i probably will still be engaging
with comic-con
yeah i mean the other question is you
know like yes it will 100
be movie studios that have movies that
need to be promoted
um for the christmas sort of calendar
the december january you know brace
of dates but how many stars are they
going to get to show up into a into a
ballroom to give
a presentation how much of that will
just be
sort of virtual as well like hey it's us
the cast of the eternals
zooming in to this conference hall
live you know or to tape you know
like how much of that is now part of
this world because i think that a lot of
people are beginning to realize
as we've watched the pr machine and the
marketing machine continue for movies
they're like lots of these stars are
thrilled
with being able to depress from their
houses and so how how eager
are people going to be to return to what
it used to be which was
i gotta go and jackass to new york and
do these shows and i gotta go to la and
do these shows and i gotta you know
i gotta then travel and do press i gotta
go the international junkets like all of
those things have changed in a way that
that i think lots of kind of actors and
and filmmakers have begin to gravitate
towards so
when does that return and is november
the time in which it'll happen
which is still an unanswered question i
just want comic-con to know that i'm
available for
all age i'll risk i'll risk the covid
and i'm used to working an empty room at
hall h as well
once before it wasn't covid it was
another
another blood disease jj it's called
aj cleared that room out everyone
everyone got a big case of the jj's and
just left and stuff
i think if i'm comic-con i see if you
will do three days
but three days straight like we're gonna
start you
at ten o'clock in the morning on
thursday and we're gonna wrap you sunday
at six p.m
can you do the marathon.com could i
[ __ ] filibuster it
absolutely yes are you kidding me oh my
god [ __ ] they just have to
update me periodically with any news so
i could be like ooh let's talk about
this but oh
that would be my dream you have to fast
the entire time as well
like you can right before you go on
no way i'd fast three days before and
i'd fast the three days journey
and [ __ ] i'd do six days dry
72 hours of kiv do i get to sleep like
it closes at night right
um i mean if if it's me
and we're making a big [ __ ] stink of
it yeah there's no sleeping
fair enough it's like we're going three
days man
mr smith goes to comic-con that [ __ ] man
let me tell you why there is uh
in chat scotty arms says i want kev to
know i'm eating a wah-wah pretzel
[ __ ] lucky bastard uh but i don't
hope i don't get wrong kachiku
sanchez says nothing on the marvel
diamond breakup that's right we should
talk about that this week
marvel announced that uh they won't be
using diamond as their primary
now diamond will still have marvel
content
trades and comics but
the comics are now not going to be
coming out of diamond they're going to
be distributed through
a division of penguin yeah what i read
penguin getting into the big boy book
the comic book business
comic books sending it to big boy
business man like
10 years ago this never would have five
years ago you never heard or something
like this those
businesses are completely different or
so they
thought um i think as bookstores began
to be more of a comic book
um you know outlet i think lots of comic
book companies have begun to diversify
their their uh their distribution beyond
diamond which for a very long time
held a stranglehold on oncoming
distribution
which seems to be coming to an end it's
true
kids for a while i mean [ __ ] the us
government investigated diamond
distributors at one point uh
because they thought they might be a
monopoly because
they had all the other competition had
gone away and diamond was the only game
in town
but uh dc of course took off in the
middle of the pandemic right they're not
exclusive with diamond anymore and now
it looks like
marvel has also gone non-exclusive
yeah i think dark horse also has an
output deal with somebody else
i think image image is the last
sort of giant who's uh who's sticking
with diamond but
you know maybe idw as well but the big
two
have uh have gone their separate ways
now it doesn't mean diamonds
going anywhere no but it does mean that
like there's blood in the water
and somebody now could come in
apparently you know look nobody needs to
compete with penguin penguin i'm sure
hopefully they know what they're doing
and you know it's the difference between
releasing a book
and releasing a weekly periodical
there must be some learning curve there
but um
it's uh it means that there might
you might see a rise of other
distributors again
like you know when i was a kid it wasn't
just diamond there was capital city
um there was another distribution
company you could get books from and
stuff
so you know this doesn't it's not a
death knell for diamond but
you know it's certainly come down from
the very high heights they were at but
you know
the nobody unaffected by that by the
covet by the outbreak by the pandemic
all of this ties directly into the
pandemic had there been no pandemic
it would be business as usual dc would
still be at diamond
marvel would still be a diamond but now
everybody's trying to figure out you
know
how to make money in a world where
nobody did for a year
yeah you know but and i think even when
we spoke
we spoke to steve jeppy about it you
know his attitude was
competition is good you know it helps
innovate it helps
you know reinvigorate and so he was
welcoming
the the the new players in in the field
and so hopefully he still feels that way
and i i do agree with him and the
competition is better than dominance
at least for the consumer so we'll see
we'll see what the effect is
at the end of the day in check gabriel
uh
perez says when was the last time you
had a nerd war of words
at a barnes and noble though buy local
it's got an absolute point man i'm not
believe me i'm not telling people
well also gabriel maybe you don't
understand it's not like these comics
are going
to the barnes and noble they'll still be
going to direct the
market comic book stores it's just they
won't be shipping from
yeah where your comic book store is
getting their books from
not where you're getting your books from
yeah you don't have to go to
nobody's gonna make you go to barnes and
noble to buy your comic books you're
fine
um and now all right so you know
the chat is good for uh suggesting
content as well man we wouldn't have uh
hit that story uh had they not man
thank you chad at the risk of pushing
the show to into the three-hour
territory did you guys check out the
last star fighters
sizzle reel that gary witta put out
no no what for a movie a would-be
remake he released a like
what is it minute sizzle reel
with all the concept art for the last
starfighter
sequel called the last star fighters
so alex rogan comes back so it's
uh yeah you can i mean if you
google it it's four and a half minutes
of just like
concept art panning and moving
and set to set to music
wow we should get gary on here
agreed i spoke to him for geeking out i
think if i remember correctly
yeah i mean he we we're on we were on
his uh talking
animal crossing talk [ __ ] gary whittaker
then gary witter
wait what did you just say jc yeah gary
wida
shared was working on thursday afternoon
he said we're very very close we're
basically on the one yard line and i
believe
it will happen so this isn't him
showing something for something that's
like uh this did project didn't work
there's still potential this is like
like restore the last starfighter
trying to capitalize i think build
something
do a deadpool yeah well he said his
quote was that they're on the one-yard
line they're
they're right there so this it's a hype
thing i think to try to get people to
to say like yes we need to see this
movie and it looks awesome
the concept art looks super cool and
it's a sequel it's not like [ __ ]
you know a remake or anything yeah
that's
that's what it looks like
you know i mean if honestly if they're
smart
and i know gary is smart you can make
the thing that does both
which is reintroduces the idea to people
who were not that big fans of the
original
while still also being a odd sequel to
the original at the same time
you know and so so yeah like i'm here
for it
i love that idea i think it'd be amazing
i'm i'm in i want it to happen i love
that movie uh kabuki kid in chat says
where is the jeff's kiss t-shirt design
we were promised to design
uh me and nate were working on it and we
locked a design
that i like i've got to show it to mark
um but it's gonna take us a minute i
asked jordan i was like hey man can we
make this
t-shirt i was like because i'll be able
to sell like 500 to a thousand during
the [ __ ] stream in one night and
stuff
and uh you know she was like look like
i'm doing
96 [ __ ] things you keep coming to me
was like can we sell this can we sell
this
so she's like let me get these dogma
scripts out and the j pops out
and then we'll focus on the shirts so
the shirts coming soon kids
coming soon i don't want to show you the
design until i could also say this is
where you can [ __ ] buy it and stuff
and jordan is the hardest working woman
in show business like dude just don't
give me one more
thing yeah who does who does your shirts
pip your shirts again uh yeah a company
called embattledclothing.com
um and i'm talking to them about another
another idea that i got
um which we'll see if it if it uh if
it's legal
at the end of the day like because i've
i've worn once or twice
a shirt that i just printed up one copy
for myself
that is you know i have two of them one
of them is
says tony no amount of money ever bought
a second of time
it's basically just a quote shirt but
another one for for aliens
where hudson is like what do you mean
they're animals man i mean they cut the
power they're [ __ ] animals
my concern had always been that's
copyrighted material like somebody wrote
that and that
that that line of dialogue is part of
you know a piece of
ip that exists that was written by a
writer that was produced by a production
company that was screened by a
distributor
um but i love that idea of being able to
just literally put screenplay
sort of snatches on a shirt so i want to
investigate the legality of doing that
if that
falls under sort of fair use if that
falls under
you know i see a thousand t-shirt
companies making a thousand t-shirts of
things that i'm pretty sure they didn't
get licensed for
um and does this fall into that problem
so if i can crack it then
some version of that will be another
shirt but
is to make a limited number make a
hundred sell them out once they're gone
even if the cease and desist comes
you're like they're gone
yeah didn't do it it's all done limited
number
i see that's the thing this guy's been
doing long enough to know all the
loopholes
the uh the uh
rock and roller 890 says what do you
think about stan sakai's usagi yujimbo
comic book series
and who would you like to play in the
upcoming netflix show
um i is that who's doing it wasn't it
like
uh taika waititi is doing usagi
jimbo i don't remember
um i mean we talked about it months and
months and months ago
um and i don't think it's pretty sure
it's not live action because it's really
hard to do
yeah i think it's animated but it might
be like 3d animation or
that pixar look at [ __ ] regardless i
can't we can't get
unfortunately we can't get involved in
questions because i have
uh this is me i'm going to start
dropping names here and [ __ ]
i have a podcast to do in about 30
minutes
uh with uh a gentleman whose name is ice
and i can't have him melting without me
i'm gonna talk to
ice cube about his weed for spodcast and
stuff
yeah you are you ain't kidding man um
so ask him ask him how he likes the scum
and villainy bar
he was there yeah i don't i i never
signed an nda so i can kind of talk
about it but yeah he was there
he walked in and he goes it's like star
wars in this [ __ ]
this was just recently for that thing
yeah yeah a couple weeks ago
very very cool it's too bad you didn't
get that on tape because if you if you
had ice cube
saying it's like star wars in this
[ __ ] as a loop
literally as you walked in the door i
have him
he's holding different uh guns
like different like space guns and he's
like this is like an
ak [ __ ] blaster and this is
like a
shotgun blaster and he's just going
through
and talking about like you know
cosplay guns as if they were like
compton guns
it was amazing it was awesome watching
him do it i'll bring it up man
i'll creep him out i'll be like hey man
what do you think of cantina bar be like
how do you know that
today was a good day um so thank you
everybody we'll cut out we'll do
questions next week and stuff do we have
a guesswork next week or no
um i don't think we do and we also need
to figure out you know if and when and
how we're going to record next week um
because sunday is easter um so we'll see
about
saturday but saturday's getting busy so
i don't know
we'll figure it out um maybe we do
friday
maybe friday i will be uh back east i'm
going back east for the grand opening of
the
boston movies pop-up man
so i'll be there to cut the ribbon um
and there are tickets available still if
people want to go to boston movies
moviespopup.com
we have another one that's opening in
des moines this week des moines iowa
movies pop up which is sold out
so thank you iowa heavens man
um and then tomorrow we announce
the next movies that opens in april
you know again these aren't opening like
permanent these are
one-week stays like it's pop-up
restaurants so we move into a restaurant
that exists
re-skin it and make our food and stuff
but it's been
fun and incredibly successful and
whatnot and it's kind of people have
gone to it referred to as like oh my god
it's like going to a mini comic con just
about this [ __ ]
um plus the food is great so i will be
in boston for that so
um if uh and then i'm gonna go down to
jersey to the stash so i might
do the show from the stash if you could
do it friday or saturday we'll figure
out a time but sunday it'd be
easter probably
i mean i i don't give a [ __ ] i happily
do it on easter that's the day the lord
[ __ ]
mark rose the best time to talk about
falcon and the winter soldier
first i'm going to talk about zombies is
that me jesus day absolutely for
heaven's sakes the og zombie
um all right but we'll be back next week
probably
indeed um because it'd be tough to
skip a week without a don't want to
break the streak
yeah oh [ __ ] um but did you have a good
time kids
did you enjoy yourselves if you did is
because jc made it happen bamf in here
and take your properties give it up for
jc give him the information again
uh some hero in twitch made a bit
dot l-y so you can go to bit.ly
slash scum n the letter
n villainy and it'll take you to our uh
our ticket page that's very helpful we
thank that person but i hate to be a
critic but i just would have made it
you know bitly slash scum but hey that's
me
and maybe they can do that because
somebody had chosen scum before
but we've got uh any number of reasons
we got some good swag
exclusive swag you get two two drinks
two special drinks we're going to do a
six hour live stream from the bar and
put
all the people who are coming in who've
missed scum and villainy for a year i've
heard i miss scum and villainy we're
gonna get to uh
we're gonna talk to them and hear about
their scum and villainy memories so
should be a good little uh birthday
party i say
pick a wall somewhere in the place it
doesn't have to be like [ __ ] out and
about like
in everybody's face could be backed by
the bathrooms and let everybody who
comes that day right on the wall and
[ __ ] put a little
big birthday celebration and writing on
the walls and
like that's cool it's another incentive
for somebody who's like i don't know if
i want to go
like i could write on a [ __ ] wall i
love coffee and they show up
um where do they get tickets bitly
slash scum n
the letter n letter villainy v i l l
a n a i n y
that was confusing bit dot lee slash
scum n v i l l a
i n y we'll just go to eventbrite and
enter scum and villain i'm sure it'll
pop
yeah same places uh you get tickets for
uh this show when we're allowed to do it
live
back to that world man yeah in a couple
of weeks we'll at least have some
clarity
we can make into some cash more
importantly
been doing this show for [ __ ] free no
cash
we like doing it in public because
people give us literally cash money man
you know what you can do with cash
pay bills yes my automobiles
my utility bills
automobiles uh
uh there would be no show tonight ladies
and gentlemen without the man who is
uh slightly beneath me and off to the
side but never
under me or whatever the [ __ ] uh the man
who's under me to the side but never
beneath me
uh give it up for mark bernard oh thank
you sir always a pleasure
that ladies and gentlemen is fat man
beyond for this week
uh i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune
in next time
same fat time same fat
challengemodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody
you